so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
what's up guys I am Thomas dobiziola
welcome to the dope as usual podcast
this is my co-host Marty O'Neal what's
up guys what's up back guys um we're
just gonna get straight into this uh
non-stop I always talked about it
earlier you guys asked for Adam Sandler
you asked for Goblin you asked for Eric
Khan every two seconds
and then this next person you ask oh I I
was telling Marty I think even more so
you finally I'm sorry it took so long
this is the fulcrum episode how you
doing man what's good my friend how you
doing thanks for having me what do you
want to go by you said all right fulcrum
your real name yeah there we go so
what's the Damian luck you just chose
your middle name middle name yeah and I
was named after my grandpa so I was like
you know what I'm just gonna make my
channel after my middle name like to
show some love to my grandpa type [ __ ]
cool yeah all right where uh is this is
your first interview yeah my first
interview all right first podcast
interview all right so here we go I'm
gonna ask the questions that most people
don't know anything about okay where are
you from where did you go to school all
this [ __ ]
um I'm from Antioch Brentwood area East
Bay okay I live 40 minutes east of San
Francisco I moved around like cities in
the East Bay throughout my life but yeah
I went to school in Brentwood yeah it's
a nice nice neighborhood cool it's a
nice neighborhood it was pretty cool
pretty cool all right yeah I don't I've
never asked how old are you I'm 23. oh
okay okay how old are you guys I'm 33
36. 36 hell yeah okay so because when we
were when Marty booked you go
deal her toy yeah that's what everyone
said yeah
because you look very young so I wasn't
sure like
are we legally allowed to smoke weed
around somebody that's not 21 in
California so that's why I wanted
because I saw some of your videos going
into schools and I'm like this
motherfucker's in school yeah I was
going to some colleges oh it was it was
it was JC's and [ __ ] yeah like um oh
they hated you bro
yeah did you even go there no random ass
classrooms I didn't attend I'll just go
Oh I thought you were running in school
no I'm not so when you're talking to
that teach that wasn't your teacher no I
was a random ass teacher bro oh and it
doesn't matter because she's like you're
gonna get reprimanded I mean okay I'll
be be reelington with you my friend I
used to go to that school like a few
years ago but I still have one more
semester if I ever want to get my
associate's degree do yeah really I'm
one semester and one class away You're
gonna go back what's your what's your
school what's your class do you have
left
what's the one left business accounting
yeah managerial accounting management oh
okay and some other math classes algebra
two is the only class I haven't done I
can't do it I sit there and go wow
that's why I sell drugs I'm leaving it's
hard are you good at geometry no wow I'm
terrible [ __ ] I almost didn't
graduate high school because I had I had
an F in algebra two algebra two I had an
F that was it I only passed algebra two
in high school as I went to Oregon and
my teacher liked me and yeah
he was cool and I was from
three miles away from his wife where she
grew up right next to Merced where I'm
from so we made a connection like
instantly he looked like [ __ ] Santa
Claus he was tight as hell
yeah yeah so okay you went to college
and you just stopped yeah I dropped out
I dropped out why
I feel like I wasn't fulfilling my my
purpose like it was taking it it was
taking me you move it just a little bit
closer it was taking me away from the
stuff I wanted to do
um going to college what were you doing
like what was your passion besides
school I was making music like when I
wasn't at school okay yeah I've been
making music way before I was doing the
YouTube stuff he showed me too yeah for
like five years now right yeah yeah so
it's on Soundcloud and whatnot yeah yeah
so you're making music you're making
beats you're making beats songs I
started producing like 10 years ago 10
years ago yeah as a little kid yeah for
like homies just I started trying to
make dubstep and then I I was messing
with odd future Wolfgang and I liked how
Tyler the Creator produced his own
tracks and that's what inspired me to
let brains all those fools too uh what
was it uh uh black and white yellow oh
come on come on that there's an album
It's split in the middle I have it I
feel dumb I know the words of the songs
it's odd it's left brain and uh someone
else they made it
thank you you're the man it's mellow
hype heavy I love that that first album
that came out was so sick oh yeah what's
the time
six minutes I think we could start a
little early if you feel okay yeah
that's fine we're gonna start smoking a
little early do you podcast interviews
here we go here we go here we go this is
zope zope hell yeah nice damn you
twisted this one up too yeah I'm trying
to roll with one paper I've been rolling
everything with two papers and they're
too fat they get air pockets yeah can
you put that other ashtray and um I mean
that's why it's just a normal joint
usually they're fat it's beaut it's
quite actually beautiful bro oh thank
you bro I actually describe dude
it's like artwork I want to tell you
five things bro like I kind of been
holding it in oh man yeah bro like you
promise you won't judge me bro go yeah
because before I got here man
at the end of the day bro I'm just gonna
let it out bro I'm obliviated obliviated
obliviated obliviated abbreviated my
homie's been waiting for it look at his
[ __ ] face he's been waiting for it
the way he had to do that down and his
fake cried on me right now you felt
appreciated you felt it I knew where you
were going
I had to do it to him
theatrical version of it bro I like the
way you did that one
thank you but besides that yeah I've
been trying to roll a little skinnier
but I have some fatter joints coming up
I just feel like they're smoking better
okay I don't know okay flavorful wow
yeah it's good right yeah it's good I've
smoked soap before it tastes exactly
like the one I smoked yeah this one
Burns good it's from uh I couldn't tell
you what company it has like the
The Fight Club Spar soap what the heck
you know what I'm saying like but it
says soap instead of a fight club on it
yeah yeah the other crazy mylar
packaging all these fancy Brands it's
one of those I'm not sure what it is
though it's fire though all right so
you're making music for 10 years what
are you making music at 13 who are you
producing music and what are you doing
because that's [ __ ] young I'm just I
started off trying to make dubstep Yeah
and then yeah I was listening to Odd
Future Wolf Gang and then
I was listening to Young lean have young
means one of my favorite favorite
artists of all time young ones dope we
need from Sweden right yeah he's from
Sweden he's cool I love Sweden too I saw
that fool in L.A one time remember oh
yeah he drove by me in like a
oh you've seen them before I saw him one
time unless the kid has the same [ __ ]
tattoos and just loves young lean and
drives a really nice porch yeah like
unless it wasn't but I remember him
traffic oh my God young lean love that
kid I I heard about him like
2015 16. like he was a kid right yeah he
was like 17 16. when he first came on
the scene I think he was like 13 14. was
he yeah like some of his first songs on
the internet he was like oh he's a kid
that came up in SoundCloud his music's
different I don't know if it if it's
like on your what you would listen to
but it's I [ __ ] like it yes it's more
leaders rap rap slight like yo I took
some pills I'm just laying here yeah
listening to music flow like that's how
it sounds like yeah it sounds like I
like it I like it good description yeah
I like it so you're 13 making music
going to school doing your thing yeah
when you start making actual videos
my whole life I've been making videos my
whole life I've been into YouTube like
doing skits with my cousins and stuff
yeah I've I've had so many different
YouTube channels that I was just like
trying to get something going like
Minecraft videos goddamn skating videos
I was doing like commentary videos at
one point too
but I think in 2018 that's when I was
watching like all these different
YouTubers like you THC Eric like all
these big ass YouTubers like making
videos smoking weed I was like you know
what I could do this and like maybe
bring my own like value to it yeah and
then that's what I started doing in 2018
but I was doing it on a different
Channel not even Damien look 925 it was
like on an old ass Channel and the
videos aren't even up anymore oh [ __ ]
yeah I started Damien luck in 2019
though okay and then you just started
going hard with the Vlogs yeah yeah at
first it was just doing like hot box
videos and stuff for the first couple
years of the channel
and then last year in 2021 I started
going into the stores with like my
stizzy or my plug play and just getting
faded in the stores and interacting with
people
and like that's vlogging dude yeah
because vlogging for and YouTube kind of
stopped and now it's starting to come
back yeah hell yeah I see people
starting to be excited again about it oh
yeah
all right so 2021 you're going hard with
the faded in this faded in that uh
basically series of you living your life
out in Antioch yes yes so are you
my question is
when you're making these videos what is
you're just you're just having fun at a
point right because as a content creator
you're not sitting there going all right
how can I make a million dollars let me
start making weed content yeah it was
it's not like that I'm assuming not at
all not at all it was um
I've always the purpose of my videos is
to let people know that like it doesn't
matter who you are it doesn't matter
what age you are like you could truly do
whatever you want to do if you put your
mind to it and I say that in every
single one of my videos every single one
of my live streams I think the way I get
I just got all this attention from
smoking in the stores to like to let
these kids know they can truly do
whatever they want to do like if in my
videos like halfway through I'll start
letting them know the truth like yo
all we have is the present moment my
friends we don't have to pass we don't
have the future you guys can truly do
this too like I'm just like a skinny
Asian kid like it doesn't matter what
age you are you could truly do whatever
you want to do
the way you said is the way Tommy Chong
said that too very similar yeah oh wow
exactly so fat uh present is the only
thing that matters basically what you
said but he said it in like a high as
[ __ ] ass way but it was great yeah older
man like wisdom he's awesome bro you
don't he's all that's why we moved in
here because it was so [ __ ] hot when
filming I thought he was gonna follow
wow I saw a bead and I went oh how was
that meeting him bro he's cool he's a
cool dude he's a very nice man but he's
awesome super cool guy and he supports
the pocket did it feel like the Matrix
broke when you met him no I don't have I
haven't had that moment yet you haven't
damn
not yet dude I'm gonna be real with you
this is trippy as hell sitting in the
goddamn studio with Marty and dolphins
[ __ ] you beat you before we started like
me and my mom used to watch your [ __ ]
yeah I appreciate that that's [ __ ]
awesome yeah man that [ __ ] that's
awesome to hear I love to hear that oh
yeah that's cool as [ __ ] I always get
stuck when people like no I won't watch
your [ __ ] too like oh different
conversation because you know when you
don't really know someone you're going
to show well it's your first interview
but if you don't know anything about
somebody yeah it's harder to like hey we
have a connection I know all you I yeah
yeah yeah it's definitely most
definitely yeah we want to be a place
that pulls from the community and like
you know like we listen to the fans we
wanna we wanna highlight people from
this community that are like coming up
here you guys set the blueprint for this
[ __ ] like this is a dope ass like
platform you've built bro like this is
crazy it's crazy I respect push trees
and the dope as usual podcast the whole
thing is crazy bro thank you I've been a
fan since since for [ __ ] Years bro
[ __ ] years
well I'm [ __ ] hyped to hear that [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah thank you dude yeah right
when I make my bro I've been a fan like
yes it's just a different connection man
now we're like oh we can talk about
certain things because you know what
we're talking about yeah it's like
there's inside jokes now you know what I
mean it can go a different different
layers yeah hell yeah hell yeah hell
yeah way different
um and you said go ahead
well I was just going to say you listen
to the podcast with your mom you said uh
back in the day me and my mom used to
watch the stizzy live resin like reviews
that Thomas would do no [ __ ] epic yeah
so because I saw a picture on your
Twitter your dad with a whole bundle of
[ __ ] weed chips yeah yeah I gave my
dad a puff coat they smoke
uh yeah yeah that's what I'm getting to
yeah so it sounds like yeah like your
parents are like kind of Yeah so
basically when I was 15 years old my dad
was like yo so
my dad's an ultra Runner he was like I'm
in a lot of pain all right Ultra Runner
yeah you said that to you guys his dad
was like a runner and then when I saw my
picture go this motherfucker's athletic
I was out in Berkeley with him and he
was like yeah I just been sore and like
I've been just looking at different ways
to like
help me feel better and then he showed
us his medical card and I was like mind
blown I was like what the hell yeah I
felt like betrayed I was like why would
you do that Dad oh you didn't smoke yet
no I was probably 14 actually yeah I was
14. I didn't smoke yet why would you do
that [ __ ] why did you do that [ __ ] it's
all good already it's just my uh
discreet business partner
look at his face he's so embarrassed I
love it sorry your dad was like yo
here's our medical card and at first you
thought like you do draw yeah that's
what I thought oh
I was gonna like yeah I thought it was
weird I thought it was weird wow so he
showed you and says this helps me yeah
he's like this helps me like I'm not I'm
sore all the time it helps me like run
better and stuff
yeah did that open your mind like maybe
we's not so bad not necessarily van
maybe a year later when I was 15 I found
out that my younger sister was in that
[ __ ] blew my mind how much younger is
she she's like two years two years ago
she's 13 smoking yeah she found your
dad's weed huh nah oh she got some
badass friends she has some okay some
badass friends well the bay too the bay
culture is like yo we get high and we
wear hoodies yeah yeah it was kind of
breezy out here everyone bro in the Bay
Area people kids are smoking in sixth
grade
dude every kids have been sixth grade
smoking weed at today I'm sorry tonight
in Merced where I used to grow up my
school yeah I remember a little kid but
I was like damn that's bad as [ __ ] were
they doing it in elementary school at
your school no not at school but I knew
of kids that had already tried weed in
my fifth grade talking about it what
that's crazy
no I won't say his name his full name
but my some guy in the name Sean he was
smoking like third second grade I
remember but his mom he was and it
wasn't there was no vape pens it wasn't
so like no you're smoking bowls off of
[ __ ] his mom's pipes that's crazy
he's crazy person on Earth if he's still
smoking bro he's still smoking yeah he's
like a full-on dad Family Guy I saw I
just got Facebook recently so I'm seeing
all these rules I haven't seen in
forever like you're a dad you sell
you're a pilot like oh [ __ ] I used to do
[ __ ] Ecstasy with that guy what the
[ __ ]
it's just weird getting a little older
it's like wait people got families now
um so sorry so your mom smokes me too or
she's wow so you so when you start
smoking if you're 15 I'm sorry you have
the exact opposite story of everyone
it's always I smoke weed my parents are
like hell no yeah except you're like no
Mom and Dad you guys get hot well so I
started smoking the first time I smoked
was when I was 16 I ate Edibles when I
was 15. that [ __ ] me up also that was
probably bad experience huh
yeah first time getting high was edible
well the first time I did Edibles it was
a decent experience I just kept eating
until I couldn't eat anymore gotcha the
food was literally couldn't go down any
further like maximum amount of food like
entered my body with the munchies man
that [ __ ] was crazy that [ __ ] was crazy
I missed those days
yeah yeah bro yeah it wouldn't happen
anymore often but so that was your first
experience smoking weed was a year later
how did you find out about your mom
um my mom didn't start until recently oh
that's right my mom didn't start till
post you being on YouTube and chat
uh
before before I started doing the Wii
tube [ __ ] before I started doing the
week tube [ __ ] maybe 20 2017. oh fumble
fumbling to ski fumblington oh Marty
that was so sad no throw it away
here this [ __ ] is smoking it's going
good I like it so you smoke at 16 what's
that situation how do you do it what is
this
okay so basically I'm out with my friend
the whole day you feel me we were just
out like shopping I don't know what the
hell we were doing
and we're on the way back home to
Brentwood he was like bro I got two
joints you wanna You Wanna Smoke them
with me rolled already yeah like
pre-rolled joints and he bought him from
this hippie kid and then I was like you
know what [ __ ] you [ __ ] it and then so
yeah we get back home it's night time at
this point we go to this empty goddamn
field at night time and we smoke both of
these pre-roll joints as fast as we
could in like under five minutes I don't
know we didn't know how to smoke it's
power smoking like both of these joints
man both of these joints we we would
have been fine off one joint bro like if
we just smoked one joint but we smoked
both of them and I started tweaking in
the field bro like oh no the Stars
started spinning and stuff I started
having like a panic attack and I was
like shaking violently type [ __ ] and I I
drove my dad's car over there I was like
there's no way I can [ __ ] drive this
back to your crib bro and then my homie
is like I'll just [ __ ] do it for you
bro and my homie my homie took the wheel
and he was valid bro he was valid I was
tweaking man I was sitting inside the
grocery store parking lot in my dad's
car in the passenger seat like tweaking
bro like having the worst panic attack
like I'm so sorry that was your first
time smoking sweet man
yeah that sucks it was it was like
telling me like bro you got to respect
this plant you just can't like can't
just do this [ __ ] like this damn two
[ __ ] joints to the face yeah
yeah she was crazy and you're saying
you're 23 so six seven years ago the
weed was [ __ ] fire it was it had to
have been fired bro okay [ __ ] trip
out yeah bro that [ __ ] was crazy that
[ __ ] was crazy do you still chill with
that friend yeah he's cool awesome cool
how long until you went back to it
good question
great question [ __ ] not very long after
maybe maybe a couple weeks or a month
because my homie had like the vape pens
we had this one homie he had hella
different flavored vape pens like every
time we'd hang out with him he'd be like
yeah I got the Indica I got the hybrid I
got the sativa you'd be like which one
do you want I'd be like [ __ ] try them
all oh [ __ ] so so this is a great great
you're in school you're in California
yeah vape pens are at the high yeah
they're at the high so how much easier
is it because I was out of school before
vape pens came out how much easier is it
to get high as a person in school
now than it was 10 years ago you had to
sneakable Cologne your hands wash your
[ __ ] head oh God all that [ __ ]
yeah these these kids are smoking in the
bathroom every day all day huh yeah yeah
and okay so it's crazy I tell like bro I
don't want my channel to
let these kids know oh you could go to
school and smoke at school but like that
is that's so dumb bro yeah I don't [ __ ]
with that it's so dumb like when I do
I'm going to a college
I'm going to a Goddamn College yeah
these ones are in high school yeah I
just think if you're in high school you
should have the fear of like yo I can't
let [ __ ] know how to smoke a
weed out here like this yeah I feel like
she's keeping on your wraps a little
because you're still a child
whooping bro okay so you're wrong with
that will beat your ass too if I was a
kid smoking in high school and I got
[ __ ] suspended for smoking in high
school yeah they would not be happy bro
okay good so your parents are still on
your ship and also like yo they say
how's my knees yeah all right cool your
dad seems [ __ ] awesome okay so when
my mom found out I got my medical card
at 18 she took me out to breakfast and
had a talk with me yeah she had a talk
with me like a like a serious time yeah
serious talk she's like you think that's
cool you like you think you're an adult
now and stuff
yeah she took you to breakfast so you
wouldn't cause a scene or something
no she just go somewhere public maybe
you got it from her like let's go public
yeah
we just talked about it I just let her
know I was like yeah I like it it helps
me with like anxiety and stuff
I was like oh no I have fun doing it I
mean like I'm I'm working and stuff I'm
working towards like goals and stuff you
know it's not like I'm lazy and just
smoking
and I just explained it to her yeah I
should take it
um should definitely iffy about it for a
while she's iffy about it for a while
but after that I didn't even have to
hide it anymore I don't even hide it
anymore
good man damn you have such a cool
[ __ ] week
my parents are cool as hell so even if
she yeah even if you're smoking weed you
want to make sure like your kid is like
getting after it that's really what I
want for my kids
it to be within them to want to go get
after it not just lay around all day I'm
gonna have kids one day I'm not gonna
let them smoke until they're 18 but they
they might smoke it before they're 18.
I'd be like yo as long as you've got
your [ __ ] together yeah that's all that
matters yeah because I definitely did
not have my [ __ ] together so I can
understand why my mom was kind of upset
but also she didn't have no [ __ ] idea
she said she did she didn't have no idea
I would but I was also selling weed and
[ __ ] I was poor it's a I think it's a
little different my mom was not she did
not take me to breakfast so I'm hearing
like hearing this is so conversations
[ __ ] with you smoking weed at all no she
didn't really know she suspected but I
was selling Halloween out of the house
oh wow but I [ __ ] love this story
yeah so your mom and dad seem so [ __ ]
are your parents like cool going into
Pizza Hut going into the gas stations
now and it's like
you're like is it a thing now that
you're out here doing these videos and
[ __ ] like I would imagine they're going
into these places
it's like a small town hey your son yeah
your son keeps smoking in the building
oh my God
oh that's great
vpns are great for security and privacy
by hiding your IP address and encrypting
your traffic to protect you from cyber
attackers you want to take your digital
security to the next level nordvpn has
offered a brand new feature to all the
desktop apps threat protection to make
sure you're safe while you're online all
you got to do is be run on the nordvpn
app and you're protected from malware
trackers ads intrusive things you didn't
sign up for across the board as we
always say are you like a Niner fan or a
buffalo fan and you just can't watch the
game because where you live nordvpn
allows you to watch the sporting events
that are in your region this also works
for other countries say you want to
watch a certain soccer game you can do
the same thing with nordvpn nordvpn
enables Netflix users to access out of
country libraries that they wouldn't
normally be able to watch at no extra
cost and saves money on other
subscriptions from other countries did
we mention that nordvpn is the world's
fastest VPN service no buffering no
lagging while you're streaming trying to
watch stuff no throttling on your ISP
bandwidth with nordvpn you're also able
to purchase flights from different
virtual locations to save money on your
ticket nordvpns protects you while
you're traveling to other places to make
sure even on unsecured Wi-Fi's that
you're safe nordvpn you can use one
account on up to six devices for the
price of one cup of coffee per month so
we have an exclusive deal with dope as
usual podcast and nordvpn if you go to
nordvpn.com forward slash Yola that is
our discount code and with that you're
going to get a huge discount plus four
free months automatically and remember
if you don't like this it's completely
money back risk-free 30-day guarantee
okay so where did you first job
first job first job okay so I was 16
years old my homie had just gotten hired
at KFC who's like bro we're hiring or
hiring bill so I applied at KFC and I
got hired on the spot bro good [ __ ] yeah
I got hired on the spot
KFC man it was crazy it was crazy and
you were smoking weed at that time when
you were ready I wasn't it wasn't oh so
you were just stacking money then yeah I
was stacking money cool yeah but it was
crazy bro I have crazy KFC experiences
like customers trying to fight me and
stuff what yeah customers call me like
derogatory names and screaming at me
like throwing trays at me and [ __ ] Bro
KFC gets crazy bro KFC gets insane it's
half a Worldstar
KFC's wild it's the one I worked on
people trying to hit you with trays you
look so nice what the [ __ ] would
somebody what did you do were you the
front person register yes oh so they're
just mad at you he's like hey little bro
give me a free biscuit I was like
he came in hella rude and I was like
maybe if he was nice I would have gave
him a free biscuit I was like sir I
can't give you a free biscuit like I'll
get in trouble you know it's like and
then he started calling me like names
and [ __ ] he's like you better give me a
a biscuit
bought me like these crazy ass slurs and
[ __ ] you know I was like damn
and then she just ate a biscuit in front
of him yeah I can't give you a biscuit
true and he's trying to hop over the
table to beat my ass but he couldn't hop
over and so he just picked up the tray
closest to him and it threw it at me
you can't legally do anything either you
have to just go all right and walk away
I saw him like a couple months later we
called the cops on his ass my manager
called the cops on how to be a tweaker
right yeah a few months later I seen him
at Goodwill and he comes up to me and he
apologized nice he was like hey bro I'm
sorry um I was going through it back
then you feel me I found God in these
past wow a couple months or whatever I
forget exactly what he said but he was
like yeah I found I found God and stuff
um I just wanted to apologize bro I was
like yeah it's all good bro I understand
[ __ ] your biscuit though yeah
wow he remembered you damn yeah did you
recognize him walking up to you yes yeah
it's [ __ ] business holy [ __ ] yeah is
he an older man older gentleman yes
probably in his 40s or 50s
wow yeah he's definitely on crack
cracking things cracking tin or the
methane he's definitely on crack he's
like you're right crackington City just
the way you said it but definitely on
crack Dan that's an amazing damn
sandwich positivity I love it I don't
have any positive tweaker stories
they're all yeah yeah really wow bad
they never came up to you and apologized
like that no dude freakers have done you
dirty like that twiggers is weirdos man
yeah and it recent reactions in Merced I
even tell you about it I forgot to tell
you yeah Merced and Antioch are very
similar oh for sure what's the
population out there maybe a hundred oh
yeah see we're like 85 so yeah we're
around the same oh you feel me then oh
you're the only KFC in town too
oh there's two
you know what there's like four KFCs I'm
not sure why there's so many KFC's it's
kind of peculiar
for KFC I was like a small town what the
[ __ ] don't want to work that close down
though
it closed that KFC was ratchet bro I see
my manager
[ __ ] having sex in the back in the
refrigerator
the manager that called the cops for you
not a different a different manager he
was laying on a bag of ketchup and he
was holding some girl up and they're
going crazy yeah
during hours during hours yeah on the
car getting paid oh all right we're just
sitting in the back and uh do vape trips
all day
the managers and stuff yeah sit on some
like bucket and do vape tricks [ __ ]
and they would like talk [ __ ] about each
other's Vape tricks antioch's crazy as
hell look at KFC [ __ ] brothels vape
trick inventions and people try to fight
you it's peculiar for sure bro all right
so how long do you worked there dude I
worked there for probably under a year
oh okay okay and I quit I didn't even
put it too weak in just left we vaping
hella hard in that McDonald's
or KFC that's when I first started
vaping bro like nicotine like I started
vaping nicotine like when I started
working at KFC
participating in The Vape company yeah
it became normalized in the back room
and then like through the country yeah I
remember those yeah I had uh somebody on
the channel remember a couple years ago
he's he does the world competitions of
smoke tricks and I had him on the show
but hey come do some stuff on camera it
was cool I was like holy [ __ ] also
it's all nicotine so yeah do with a
blunt do the blood lots of people that
do tricks don't even have nicotine in
their Vape though it's just juice yeah
well I guess you get lightheaded huh I
don't know I wouldn't want to vape
anything if there was nothing in it no
it sounds like you're [ __ ] drinking
non-alcoholic beer nowadays I wouldn't
even want to vape anything if it's not
like weed yeah you just still smoke
nicotine Vapes no I haven't touched one
since 2019 I used to be on those heavy
good it was hard to quit good what'd you
do to quit mom what'd you do to quit um
I mean I was trying to quit for like a a
solid year but I think after this one
shroom trip I was like yeah like I was
smoking the nicotine on the shroom trip
and I was like yo this shit's not good
for me I was tripping out and I was like
this is not good for me but every time I
hit it after that I was like yo I don't
[ __ ] with this [ __ ] oh man your brain
open yeah that was weird bro oh good
that's good though man
cleansing of your [ __ ] toxins in your
brains too huh yeah yeah I like shrooms
like once or twice a year it's a good
restart yeah it's like they're
they'reapeutic animals 100 I like doing
them in nature by myself in my room by
myself from the or in the room in the
dark yeah
I've never done them in the woods or
anything though you should Nature's
really fun to do it that would be fun I
just don't trust
myself if I'm gone yeah in nature you
can't really remember California you're
like what if there's like a mountain
lion you gotta be on my [ __ ] this is cow
mountain lion there's mountain lions out
here not cougars uh coyotes and [ __ ]
Bobcats yeah
Bobcats
what you know Herobrine
it's a from Minecraft what's that is
this um super rare
like
threat in nature and Minecraft Herobrine
oh my God like okay gotcha damn my
brother my brother little brother's
gonna flip his [ __ ] nobody's about to be
19 and he goes hard on the Minecraft
still yo I'm my bad bro what's up I'm
[ __ ] up I'm getting Ash on this
you're fine you're fine okay you're good
I promise
um damn dude we're talking about
Minecraft the biggest threat oh tripping
all right when you start [ __ ] with
shrooms
oh oh [ __ ] bro
I think the first time I tried it
was 2019 was 2019. I just did it by
myself in my room like at midnight bro
first time yeah it was fun wow it was
probably like
dude like I had never been that like
awoken before I was looking at my hands
and [ __ ] like
I was like dude this is what it feels
like to be a human this is beautiful I'm
so grateful for everything and I was
going outside and looking at the sunset
I was like dude like I'm so [ __ ]
grateful for this [ __ ] why do I be like
tripping about the littlest like
inconveniences and [ __ ] yeah and like
yeah I was just feeling mad grateful my
first time doing shrooms and like I was
tripping all the way till sunrise
my there's like random cats outside too
bro this [ __ ] was beautiful that [ __ ]
was so beautiful man that's really
beautiful I love it yeah I love that's
your first trip yeah oh man I have solid
grams two solid grams for your first
trip that's that you went in yeah and
yeah it was pretty crazy
I was watching YouTube videos and [ __ ]
too I was like this [ __ ] this this
[ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy looking at my
laptop I was like
damn this is like some alien [ __ ]
infectionology how the [ __ ] did they
make this I was tripping out mushrooms
will break you down to the core elements
like why is this here my name is that
why does it sound like that this is my
face so I go through life with this face
and people see this face okay what do I
do looking in the mirror is tripping
weird and then you think about your
siblings and family go they have their
own lives exactly bro yeah I just see
them and they interact and they do their
thing exactly it makes you like do
people just spawn
and you start thinking a little crazy
[ __ ] things and then you find out
that these are real conspiracies already
I'm like oh [ __ ] I didn't know that but
mushrooms are fun have you had a
conspiracy theories oh yeah huh you mess
with conspiracy theories uh I mean I see
the [ __ ] I just don't I don't really go
into them yeah
I don't know everything is I think yeah
depending on how you look at it that's
the truth do you want a uh another joint
um I got this one all right if you had a
trip going sideways or not so well
uh mushroom trip any kind so I've had
like um
definitely challenging trips like trips
that forced me to sit down and like like
take accountability for [ __ ] you know be
like damn okay maybe like I do gotta
switch some things up in my life I'm
like challenging trips like
not necessarily like Terrible Bad trips
but like trips that were hard to go
through for sure but they taught me they
taught me something it seems like you're
trying to be on a path to like keep
leveling up and bettering yourself and
stuff yeah yeah I don't like tripping
too much like once once or twice a year
like two grams two grams I feel you the
last one I had made me go I got [ __ ] to
do I can't be doing this [ __ ] like this
so yeah I did it on the podcast I went
home I was like dude six hours out of my
day it takes a lot of energy out of you
yeah that too for a few days you kind of
feel like time off yeah I just feel like
I'm not fully awake yet yo yo yeah so I
I feel you on that they're beautiful
though they're beautiful moderation if
you have nothing to do I think they're
[ __ ] the best thing ever I mean if
you have nothing to do with no worries
trip for a day
I'm waiting for that day I got one
entire mushrooms at home one day yeah
some freeze-dried mushrooms freeze jars
they're like blue and [ __ ] they're grown
by some
like Boutique mushroom brand I don't
know what the I don't know what brand it
is but they're fire no [ __ ] you already
tried them no I haven't but just looking
at them oh my God the blue crystals in
the video yeah bro it's stupid crazy you
look stupid crazy
do you have any aspirations to try out
like DMT or any sort of like anything
above Beyond mushrooms I don't think so
I'm very satisfied with um
the herb and the goddamn that's where
I'm at the sippington cities you know
Pacific and cities
wait sippington City shall we love it is
that what you call drinking stuff yeah
love it yeah
[Music]
I don't want to do any more drugs I
don't want to do any more drugs I've
never tried acid me neither really yeah
it's man-made
um
I just got scared when I was like 11 my
aunt we talked about my aunt's friend
yeah my aunt and her friends do it a lot
in high school for real and her friend
win schizophrenic but her mom's also
schizophrenic serious black predisposed
to it yeah but also
like yo I'm not risking that [ __ ] could
you imagine me get a bad Acid Trip
already the show's over
uh no thanks what a [ __ ] shame no
thank you we got [ __ ] to do yeah I got
[ __ ] to do I want my brain here that's
why I'm scared to do it too bad reason
yeah I'm nervous like what if it changes
me
yeah like for what oh I thought that was
a cheers you're allowed to cough what
was that noise it was my friend an
elephant trying to dying back there no
the um
a camera noise
yeah it turned off thank you thank you
um okay so Marty said Marty already
looked it up because I have no idea I
don't watch Star Wars fulcrum's from
Star Wars that's how you got the name
yes sir it's from a Star Wars cartoon
Star Wars Rebels it was this cartoon
that came out in 2014
it took it takes place after episode
three are you into Star Wars nope oh my
little brother's [ __ ] heavier and he
does he helps us with the comments and
[ __ ] yeah so I know he's in the chat
like it's this it's from this one he's
that he's that guy
so Star Wars um nah dude I mean I've
seen them all I've seen all the old ones
I've seen the new ones I couldn't tell
you I can't tell them apart you never
watch the mushrooms I feel like that
would be fine watch the Star Wars on
shrooms
that would be fun I think doing anything
in light moderation of shrooms can make
it intense for real you're gonna be like
a gram and a half of shrooms and doing
something I think that would make almost
anything yeah a little more like most
definitely does my grandma have enough
for me to trip out bro yeah you'll start
seeing little things I think you start
seeing the patterns and start feeling
the I get it like in my chest I feel
like
like I can feel each breath that's when
I know I'm starting to [ __ ] trip a
little bit
bro I start feeling it when I start
feeling like my body is like there's no
bones in it I don't know how to describe
it but I just feel like
I'd be moving in ways I never moved
before bro moving in ways I never moved
before I'd be like damn I'm peculiar and
I'm okay with it I'm peculiar and I'm
okay with this at the end of the day
necessarily just as a human yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah we're [ __ ] weird
being weird yeah yeah why not I don't
know I think I think
all the kids that were weird in school
yeah and high school were just normal
people and the people that were like
you're weird turned out to be the prude
kids and now they're kind of I guess
those are the recipes for Karen's hmm
that's how I feel like where did those
people track them back to kids where did
you grow from you were the kid that was
a [ __ ] [ __ ] in school or you were
the kid that called me a weirdo for
liking certain music or what kind of kid
were you I was a [ __ ] weird kid were
you popular no damn no hell no whoa
everyone knows me yeah and I smoke weed
and I know all the fools I described
this the other day to you or to Rosie do
you have a senior circle like the quad
where all the cool kids hung out only
like there's a bench most definitely you
know what I'm saying like I know all
those fools that sell them weed
all right I'll see you guys later later
and I go chill with my friends the
[ __ ] drug addicts
so I know everyone yeah
but I don't care to chill yeah with
everyone that's different when you're
making money off everybody because you
don't give a [ __ ] I didn't it wasn't
necessarily that it was more of like I
was real real real dumb as a kid and
like I thought remember my music [ __ ]
it's on the radio all this commercial
[ __ ] these fools like oh you you
probably do some stupid [ __ ] get away
from me I'm gonna listen to my
underground [ __ ] my Bay Area [ __ ] like
if you [ __ ] with that we'll probably be
friends but if you're a pop star I was
very anti-commercial but yeah I was very
anti-mainstream as a kid and I think it
was really stupid of me because
who cares if what you like you might be
you might be awesome to chill with we
are very similar bro yeah we're very
similar I hated that about myself as a
kid dude I really didn't like that now
that I look back I'm like what a dumbass
are you judging people yeah I judge
people like oh that's your favorite song
at all because I was like this some
[ __ ] commercial [ __ ] and they go
well just don't listen to the commercial
song Let's listen to something else of
him and I went oh this is cool and now
what was it yesterday the whole drive
back from my I had his albums I'm like
no this was time yeah Drake Smith was
tight he's hard but as a kid I was like
no no that's too commercial for me [ __ ]
that he's on the radio no thanks his
first mixtape that go back to that one
but you see what I mean I didn't even
give that a chance so that was me in
high school like oh you guys listen to
that no I'm cool go to the party I'll
see you guys later I'm gonna go do
[ __ ] coke with my friends so that's
the kid I was in school yeah to answer
your question yeah but no I don't like
being around people and you know it oh
[ __ ] you look different around me what
was that it's a Drake song oh see I have
no idea
I feel like I just had to let that one
out yeah that's fine that's fine look
you didn't have the headphones on yeah
I'm about to [ __ ] drop some [ __ ]
beats on it
um as soon as Drake's not rapping I I
pretty much change the song I don't like
I don't like love songs you don't like
love songs I don't really like r b bro I
like love songs I just don't like r b
that much and Rosie loves it so I I like
it but then again it goes back to me as
a kid like oh Shanti on the radio that's
what I thought as a kid and now I hear
and go oh that's why everybody loves
Ashanti Ashanti's dope but as a kid I
was mad ignorant so it goes back to that
dude I I
left myself out of a lot of circles as a
kid I think because I'm like no I'm good
I'm gonna do okay you guys don't do
smoke you don't smoke weed imma go over
here
that's how I felt I was a weird kid in
high school would you like what kind
like no one knew me I was the quiet kid
in class like oh I was always kind of
like awkward
and kind of introverted I didn't have
too many friends say I feel you seems
like you're the opposite of that now
walking up I think I grew into myself
for sure did you have to talk yourself
up into that like I never just had a um
realized yo I just
[ __ ] I got to go after my purpose and
Mission peripheral got to go out to my
perfect submission my bad I'm faded
you're good man I'm about to take a trip
to dabbington City go for it are you
smoking hasherizing
yeah right first time ever on the
podcast right no no I think we put the
e-rig on here before once
but you know what I think I'm wrong I
think that is the first time anybody's
taking a dab on the show
well there he is the first one Exquisite
too
no bro hold up before we can continue I
just got to say your vocabulary is
making my day that's a base [ __ ] I love
it bro it sounds like E40 in like 1992.
oh this is spectacular that's how I love
I love that vernacular
vernacular that's a good one too this is
oh yeah I just love uh
I had to point it out bro I was making
me laugh I used to always um play E-40
songs that like school dances and oh
you're from the bay that is basically
like playing vitamin C
remember that the graduation day song
it's E40 in the bay like you play e-40.
God damn for real no the bay is a
different place definitely a whole
different culture different Culture by
itself um people keep telling me to move
out here to LA and I'm like I don't want
to leave the bay I feel you but leave
the bay
you think I should yeah because you know
what you can go back yeah you're right
but [ __ ] bro I know but that smile on
your face kind of tells me like I know
you're right but I also don't want to
leave the bay
I love it I love how slow paced it is
yeah
and you're not in [ __ ] SF so it's not
like
it depends on what your goals are I mean
what's best case scenario for the next
the next couple years ago is exactly how
you want it like what would that look
like
I just want to keep um go to my Yodi
land brand you know just keep um
[ __ ] move out I'm about to get my own
place this month nice yeah good [ __ ]
dude this month same same city
same I think I'm gonna move to Oakland
or Berkeley Oakland or Berkeley
Berkeley's really nice I felt perfectly
I like Berkeley too it's peaceful yeah
it's so quiet Everything feels like
winter break
people are just chilling the leaves are
falling and [ __ ] I love her
oh it just feels like no school I don't
gotta work today that's Berkeley I saw
one of your videos you work at a
dispenser yeah I've actually worked at
two dispensaries two dispensaries do you
actively work at a dispensary I don't
work at one right now oh okay yeah when
did you first start
okay so I I got hired at one at the end
of
I want to say
let me think when was that it was either
20 the end of 2020 or 2021
yeah it was I got hired at a dispensary
at the end of 2020.
and that was my first foot in the door I
started off as the sign flipper no [ __ ]
Street yeah FTP yeah that [ __ ] was crazy
bro I was just dancing my heart out
singing like singing my favorite songs
listening to my favorite songs bro that
[ __ ] was so [ __ ] fun bro because I
was used to like
being stressed out at work you feel me
doing like a bunch of crazy ass
different [ __ ] at work but then I was
just singing and dancing on the side of
the street and that [ __ ] was so [ __ ]
bro I was so happy doing that [ __ ] Bro
16 an hour bro what the [ __ ] yeah damn
that's hot I know people get paid more
than you think holy [ __ ] you think
that's yeah that's pretty that's I mean
that's pretty low now what's minimum
wage now I don't know a lot of people
are getting paid like 17. 17 out that's
when I was crushing it at my job as an
adult like 17. yeah one two three [ __ ]
17 is pretty [ __ ] crazy 17's a lot
[ __ ] that's a lot that's kind of like
normal where I'm from
well the bay is so expensive dude you
could probably find a place down here
for the same price man and this is
[ __ ] L.A my fingers are black look at
that [ __ ] you're from the breaking up
that weed from rolling up design tin is
that what it is designed oh okay I
thought that was the Stream
would you call it crystal glass or
Crystal City uh Crystal Farms Crystal
Farms sorry Crystal glass truffle white
truck
it looks [ __ ] ridiculous it was like
Barney
okay so you worked two dispensaries and
then oh sorry you sign flipper then you
start being a blood tender what's next
yeah basically I was signed flipping one
day these jackass kids they're they were
just being mean to me and pointing a gun
at me type [ __ ] and like harassing me
and then basically like I went back to
the dispensary I told him I was like
yeah
um this sucks yeah and so they they
promoted me though and I started working
through the drive through drive through
one spot yeah oh god what the whole time
I work six days a week there bro it was
nice drive through weed [ __ ] yeah it was
true it was chill bro and the tips were
crazy bro the tips were crazy sometimes
I walk out that [ __ ] with like [ __ ] 150
bucks like damn on tips a day yeah oh
crushing it I've never so you're talking
about like McDonald's you pull on the
side of the building yeah put your order
in yeah but basically you place your
order on the website online and then you
pull up you show your ID they scan your
ID and then you get them you get your
order and then you drive away you don't
have to sell them [ __ ] they already know
what they want yeah
well that's [ __ ] amazing we're
sleeping in Orange County on that show
yeah I mean they only they only started
that for covet though so they don't do
that anymore I can see why okay okay the
state only allowed that for kovid ah
wouldn't that be badass right now that
would be badass bro that is genius holy
[ __ ] I don't gotta do nothing you don't
have to leave order on the way thanks
you don't have to leave your car bro
so I'm sorry hold on you're just
flipping a sign these fools come put a
gun at you that's crazy yeah I made a
story time on my Channel about it that's
[ __ ] up it was kind of yeah I was I
was scared bro because I sign flipped a
couple more times after that and every
time I was out there I was just scared
but I'll be right these fools are just
walking by I was like hey
they're in the car you're in the car and
then so they would pull up one time they
would be like hey um
why'd you hit my car with your sign like
they're messing with me because I didn't
hit their car my son and I'm like yeah
I'm gonna beat your ass you feel me it's
like give me all your money type [ __ ]
you funny and then yeah they drove away
and I was like oh they're just they're
[ __ ] with me like they're just
messing with me so I get back to
flipping my son listening to my goddamn
young mean listening to my goddamn baby
smooth type [ __ ] you feel me and then
[ __ ] like 30 minutes later they
pull back around bro and this time
they're like flashing the gun at me type
[ __ ] they're like they're like yeah you
think we're playing around huh you think
we're playing around huh I don't know
why you're still here bro I don't know
why now I'm thinking about maybe they
were selling weed and they didn't want
me promoting the dispensers
uh that could be a a completely
reasonable thing in their brain yeah
because that shit's real out here too
that's crazy
really they flashed a gun at me they're
like yeah we told you we're not playing
around bro you got to give us all your
money and I was like I'm just 16 I'm I'm
only 16 years old guys you feel me I
don't have any money I'm just trying to
I'm just trying to It's my job what the
[ __ ] I was I was like [ __ ] I was 21.
it's like bro I'm a kid yeah yeah I get
you there's no cash register here [ __ ]
I'm flipping a sign what the [ __ ] for
real I didn't have any money bro and
then yeah they drove away and then 30
minutes later they pulled back up again
they pulled back up again
and laugh about like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that's when you just shot him oh [ __ ]
yeah bro hey that shit's crazy bro that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] crazy well that [ __ ]
sucks that bugs me bro ah but at least
it got you on the inside of the Disco
and [ __ ] I guess I guess but no your
YouTube's cracking to the point so
correct me if I'm wrong here looking at
your Twitter October 24th 200k Subs by
tonight
now here we are today in to some early
December
you're up over [ __ ] 700k on YouTube
right yeah yeah
I have I had 500 Subs back in
um like a month November 12th
[ __ ] 500 Subs back in um April or May
I had 500 subscribers on YouTube
April or May yeah may this year may oh
okay okay 500 Subs on YouTube oh okay
okay yeah because I because I thought it
was not the wrong date I must have
pulled the wrong day I pulled because I
pulled some sweets from your [ __ ]
Twitter
and it said October 24th 200k sub by
tonight November 12th 500k Subs
are we High
no wait what happened
okay I'm gonna tell you one thing bro
I'm definitely [ __ ] high right now no
you're good you're good now what we were
saying was he pulled up your Twitter and
it said November 12th thank you for 500k
oh yeah November 12th I did hit 500
games no so not may may was 500. oh
500 yeah 500. so we're all high okay
it's just confusing because these are
such astronomical numbers that's what
like I'm getting to like yeah crazy bro
it's mind-blowing bro it's crazy because
I was telling him uh when I first
started really really doing YouTube by
2019 yeah I gained like 120 in a month
just my videos everywhere in a month in
a month and then I was like wow I never
seen that before holy [ __ ] if YouTube's
fun I like YouTube this is sick and then
you showed me the number I go holy [ __ ]
that's awesome are you monetized
um you know what I choose not to
monetize a lot of my smoking videos oh
but like the channel is monetized oh my
God that's awesome some of my videos are
monetized
let's go God damn yes
you do a lot of you're not showing packs
or nothing like that or I try not to I
try not to see that's what [ __ ] I smoke
a lot of flour though but not too much
on camera nowadays yeah because you try
to keep it somewhat I go to dabington
City this is my favorite thing they
don't [ __ ] with you huh yeah or the pipe
the pipe is pretty good too oh [ __ ]
because you said one of the First videos
I watched was cool Lotto one of my
videos yeah my first one ever hit a
million and there was like a 20 pack in
the video but I left it in there I was
like it's okay it was in the corner
right I was like is in the corner we're
showing this weed
and I think that's where they're like yo
you can't be monetized what are you
doing here yeah so it's smart for keep
thank you for keeping it you're able to
make money in something they take that
from you it's hell to get that [ __ ]
back yeah we just got it back yeah
that's why I've been choosing not to
monetize most of my videos yeah because
the only videos no I'm not gonna smoke
yeah like let's say you got to do an
update video or something you know
but you're staying on YouTube's good
side that way yeah you know what I mean
you're not [ __ ] out there trying to
monetize off of I smoked a zip yeah yeah
you know because they're they just frown
upon it and then they start hating you
and then you get [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
now did they do you not have a tick tock
page I do have a tick tock because I
couldn't find it I thought maybe they
like kicked you off or something gray
saber fulcrum gray saber oh okay I just
didn't know that [ __ ] was yours some
Star Wars because there's so many people
that have names that could be you on
there and that are posting your videos
and [ __ ] like that's that's how I blew
up my page man so oh through Tick Tock
so when I had 1 000 subscribers I was
inspired by Andrew Tate I was inspired
by snico how they had their following
repost their clips
like and that's how they would grow
sorry I'm sorry sneak as a Mexican dude
or like he's like tan yeah okay I know
you're talking about yeah yeah no jumper
before yes right yes okay and [ __ ] I
was inspired by that so at 1 000
subscribers I told my following yo
Whoever has the most viral Tick Tock
clip of my video in two weeks and you
use these hashtags on the video hashtag
Yogi gang hashtag fulcrum come in
hashtag just all these different like
hashtags on made up whoever has the most
viral video with these hashtags in two
weeks I'll give you a hundred bucks oh
that 1000 brought me to 5K and I did it
and I did it at 5K subscribers I did
that same method again posted it on my
Instagram just a screenshot of my notes
and [ __ ]
and I was like Whoever has the most
viral video in two weeks will get free
Yogi land apparel merchandise and
they'll get a hundred bucks again
100 yeah it was a hundred bucks so I
just Sprite your [ __ ] yeah I went from
5K to 100K after that one yeah
damn yeah and I haven't done one since
then you utilized that [ __ ] right yeah
because people make clips of ours like
yo why are they more viral than our own
page they make do they get more views
they get more views but like times five
and [ __ ] huh yeah dude there's one that
has like six million views on Tick Tock
and our same clip has like 87 000 views
what is it it's [ __ ] the ddg's voice
thing that was on dude he was trolling
a little closer are you gonna be good
he had to have been trolling he had to
have been that voice that was funny I
asked him I'm looking at his eyes I
asked him after he goes nah man but the
way he said I went oh man that was you
telling me yeah like it has to be bro it
has to be I don't know he didn't like
fully say I don't know that's trippy he
was sitting right here yeah yeah this is
this the same Studio whoa yeah but dude
that's trippy um
feel you people's other Clips will go
more viral than your own it's the
weirdest [ __ ] yeah for sure even if it's
the same clip same exact clip bro same
exact caption I don't get it it's just
the algorithm I don't know it's
algorithm so that's how you're pumping
you're funneling your algorithm to push
to your YouTube yup and now I've been
pushing from my YouTube to my music good
you're doing something that people can
like grab onto because music's forever I
think people can watch a video a few
times so you can listen to a [ __ ]
song 150 times yeah straight this next
music video I'm dropping Bros gonna
[ __ ] go crazy was it what is it
called uh all at once everyone's been
asking me fulcrum you got to drop your
outro song fulcrum you gotta drop your
outro song all the beats in my videos
and all the music I play at the end you
make yeah I make them yep let's go so
[ __ ] everyone's like you gotta drop
your outro song for [ __ ] months bro
like probably tens of thousands of
comments telling me to do that [ __ ] and
yeah I'm gonna drop it with a video with
some of the best videographers and
editors in the game bro
who did the last one what's it called
uh we wrote it down my way no my way out
yeah
the I saw the clip that you posted on
Twitter yeah yeah
they went crazy they went crazy this is
the same team same team so what Friends
filmed that video for me with my GoPro
really yeah and this time
this video I was working with some real
videographers yeah this is gonna go
stupid imagine that editing with like
crazy videographers yeah because that
was just a GoPro then wow
good [ __ ] hell yeah I'm gonna go stupid
bro so you're funneling this in a in a
way that should be because look when I
did when I started doing my [ __ ] it was
Snapchat I started funneling myself the
second biggest [ __ ] Snapchat in the
damn Snapchat Snapchat nice and I was
funnily back to my check out my YouTube
video and I could see in the analytics
like 86
views came through Sam like holy [ __ ] so
you could see that on the back end too
right oh yeah your analytics whole day
so you you crack the code essentially
yeah good [ __ ] man
good [ __ ] it's just the beginning like
even though I've got all this like
success like in a few months type [ __ ]
it's just the beginning I have so much
more [ __ ] to do this live [ __ ] is a
marathon bro like it's definitely a
[ __ ] Marathon gotta keep going bro I
gotta keep going with this [ __ ] and I'm
happy to do this bro I'm so grateful
this is my full-time job now bro when's
the last time you had an actual job two
months ago I quit my job at the second
dispensary I got hired at two months ago
yeah and then just started doing
full-time every all the content yeah I
quit at 5 000 subscribers
because you knew you were this is what
you're gonna do yeah
yeah my mom I didn't even tell my mom a
week later my mom comes to my room what
the [ __ ] you thinking you quit your job
types how'd you find a game with a bike
a little closer yeah yeah how'd she find
out
um one of my co-workers is friends with
her I guess
yeah one of your co-workers snitched you
out to your mom yeah
God damn
no I don't think she snitched me out I
don't think she snitched me out she just
said like oh you know today's not
working here anymore what happened to
you gotcha never mind sorry I couldn't
mean to call you [ __ ] instigator but
then I told my mom I was like Mom this
shit's gonna work
and so I told her this is going to work
we'll share with her now
like how does she feel about it uh she's
proud of me she's proud of me
oh yeah so they're both supportive
they're like go after it yeah I've made
videos with my dad before my mom's been
in some of my videos too no [ __ ] yeah
your mom and dad both Filipino you said
so my dad's Filipino my mom's um
my mom's like German and Irish and stuff
yeah got you
and stuff because Rosie she's your dad
are they are they hello Filipino because
Rosie's side of her family is Hell
Filipino for real okay so my grandpa and
my grandma are they're crazy ass
cookouts and [ __ ] yeah back in the day
yeah back in the day
the first one I ever went to was was
Rosie's the first time I ever ate that
[ __ ] was so it was before I started mean
[ __ ] but wow
Filipino food is this [ __ ] I don't know
anything why'd you go um you're vegan
right yeah why don't you go vegan oh
like five years ish fish around there
really I was vegan for a year in 2020.
how'd you feel
I liked it it was cool
what made you go back
I don't know I just missed it I missed
the meat and [ __ ]
I felt like I wasn't it's very hard I
felt like I had to eat like a monster to
be healthy yeah and that's what I'm
trying to do right now with all the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I couldn't
um
do you allow myself to eat that much
food yeah you have to eat a lot of
[ __ ] food dude it's crazy
but then again everybody should be
eating a lot of raw ass Foods or Whole
Foods very true because that [ __ ] makes
yourself full too though you can eat
this much of a salad with all natural
shame like dude I can't finish this [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah six [ __ ] hamburgers
I can annihilate that [ __ ] brain yeah
so real quick back to your music your
music yeah so you're you're funneling
this out you're tunneling all the
momentum into and trickling it down to
your to things that you're first
passionate about so your YouTube is
actually going to push your music videos
because everybody's a fan they're like
I'm a fan I'm gonna watch a music video
yeah no matter what I'm gonna go listen
so no matter what you have the momentum
and the hype behind yourself are you
going to keep going harder on the music
content what is this next step right
here like in three months what's your
goal like I want to have [ __ ] five
music videos or like no I want to be
putting out I'm gonna be dropping my
next music video on my CH on my main
Channel
yeah monetize it too there you go
[ __ ] but yeah it's gonna go crazy
it's gonna go crazy it's gonna push my
music further I plan on doing shows in
2023 oh [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna do some
shows in 2023 but yo you know what man
I'm gonna tell you one thing I started
the content for fun bro and I like um
getting my message out there man my the
reason I do this [ __ ] is to let these
kids know bro I've already said this
[ __ ] but you guys can do whatever you
want bro like
I want I want my videos to let people
know they could truly do whatever they
want to do and people hit me up all the
time fulcrum your videos motivate me to
go to the gym I don't even go to the
goddamn gym it's just our motivation
yeah so it's like fulcrum your videos um
inspired me to apply it and get a better
job I felt stuck in this job and it's
like that's I just want to let them know
like Yodi family we're the only things
that like
we're the only people that hold us back
from doing the [ __ ] that we gotta do you
feel me now let them know too we got to
keep it pushing you tell me you woke up
today because your ass has a goddamn
[ __ ] purpose in Mission you
feel me like real [ __ ]
you funny I love the positive that's
what I was really like pleased about
when I started like going through all
your stuff is to find that message it's
like I'm gonna get your attention with
all this crazy Off the Wall [ __ ] but
then once I have it I'm gonna fire you
up and leave you better than before you
were when you started watching the [ __ ]
yeah that's why I really [ __ ] with um
your videos two at first because you
would always say like it doesn't matter
who you are exactly you could do
whatever it's the whole podcast Mission
yeah yes dude exactly yeah that's why I
resonated with this [ __ ] bro like
because you should
was has always been genuine bro it's
always been genuine and organic bro
that's the whole point because it's
crazy that I'm here right now it's just
been that organic bro when you guys hit
me up my [ __ ] brain explode what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah like bro
like and this is my first podcast and
interview like I've ever done bro thank
you for coming here done it with anyone
else bro real [ __ ] appreciate that dude
yeah I saw you with Eric I'm like okay
Eric knows I'm okay cool and then I talk
I asked God when you're saying last week
I'm like hey have you ever met this
Falcon but he's like no I've talked to
him he seems really cool yeah and Marty
when he hit me up on he hits us up in DM
and he's like seems really nice I go
because I've met other you know I've met
content creators off the internet before
yeah
and that's all I'm gonna say like I I
hang out with who I hang out with
because they're genuine nice people I
don't like to meet that many people that
do content mainly and chill because I
feel like there's ulterior motives we're
lucky to have Central Community you know
what I mean like cool people yeah so the
people that we do bring around all the
time are so genuine like they're they're
cool [ __ ] bro that's why we
were like I was asking around like have
you ever met this is he a nice person
that's my first thing like is he cool or
not he was kind of you kind of a dick
like oh then I'm good bro because I I we
can have a hell of fools on the show I'm
like that guy was it that guy's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] or that guy's a little
[ __ ] creepy I'll see him do some
weird [ __ ] like we don't want to bring
people on with that with a message of
something that's not positive and no
matter what everything you've said has
been super [ __ ] positive and
everything you've
put out has never been
like on some hateful [ __ ] I feel
and I definitely that's my cool wants in
this story and it's on video it's my
most uh popular video some kid comes up
to me well I'm just making my video bro
I hadn't even I hadn't even smoked in
the store I was just pouring up my soda
and this kid starts filming me bro he
starts filming me type [ __ ]
and I lost my cool I was like
um get the [ __ ] out of my face bro get
the [ __ ] out of my face and I was
calling them some names and [ __ ] you
feel me and then I poured my soda oh
this is the one me and you watched the
first thing we watched went oh
filming you like how like I'm being you
just yeah I didn't know you hadn't
smoked it I just always saw pieces of it
yeah I didn't smoke in there um does he
watch your videos then and knew what
you're gonna do or something I don't
know I think he was just upset that I
was in the
I don't know he was trying to be B cam
because I I was I only had like a
thousand subscribers there was no way he
knew who I was absolutely no way he knew
who I was oh so he's being weird to you
yeah he was just hating on me
but it is what it is you feel me that
it's my most viral video but I hate like
watching that [ __ ] and feeling the way I
felt like
like got super mad at him and called him
that [ __ ] you feel me I got sick like
the next day bro I got sick the next day
yo what the [ __ ]
what's wrong
I thought I was getting cold oh [ __ ]
it's all good I've had that happen where
something like real bad happens and you
get sick the next day yeah you got sick
the next day after that
oh so you're you're a nice person I feel
you I I get what you're not sick but
like I got physically sick like the flu
yeah I've never gotten like that I've
just felt like
dwelling on it for days and days and
days and days because I that
confrontation like you said that feeling
that confrontational I don't like having
that [ __ ] yeah smile like like on some
restaurant [ __ ] I'll let it go
because I don't like so confrontational
that [ __ ] sorry my friends no my friend
John's very like hey I need this done
now be cool be cool that's his job but
he's in a good way he's never a piece of
[ __ ] but me I'll be like hey man they
probably fine if they forgot yeah like
it's fine because I'm like I don't like
the feeling of like confrontation
because if you get me pissed I'm gonna
get [ __ ] pissed and I don't like that
yeah that's like it's not a good feeling
yeah it's actually the worst [ __ ]
feeling ever and having to hit someone
is the other worst feeling ever I don't
like that [ __ ] I don't know you know
like it's like an evil [ __ ] grocery
feeling so you got sick the next day
yeah
I gotta see it so how did that end you
poured your drink out on him and then
just dipped out of there
yeah poured my drink on him basically he
was like this is what pissed me off he
was like I came at you all nice and now
you're mad
and that's what pissed me off because
bro like why like he didn't come up to
me nice and why like
this [ __ ] just pissed me the [ __ ] off
bro and then I poured my soda on him and
I walked out the store and I went home
well we all get pissed dude and then we
all get pissed but the fact that you
feel shitty about it I think kind of
tells the kind of character of a person
like I wish I would have got so [ __ ]
upset
that's good that's a good way and you're
already like uh how am I gonna grow from
this and that's why you're taking
mushrooms and [ __ ] like do you follow
raw OG Brandon Ross I was just thinking
that I do subscribe to him for a minute
too yo he is like that too with the
mushrooms like so what is my purpose in
this all right I'm taking this is my
intention like he's yeah he's the one
that opened my eyes meditated on [ __ ]
mushrooms before how was that trippy you
go to different worlds oh well you're
doing weird deep breathing and [ __ ] yeah
I mean I like to meditate like when I'm
not tripping but I was just doing it
like while I was coming up on the trip
that [ __ ] was crazy bro like a real
meditation like yeah for like [ __ ] 40
plus 45 minutes bro more than 45 minutes
for sure what are you doing within that
time like what are you saying
seeing [ __ ] visuals and like seeing
different worlds and [ __ ] bro this is
crazy
yeah crazy bro did you talk to anybody
no no no okay like it doesn't get that
crazy okay so mine mine did I was
talking to [ __ ] you were in
conversations and [ __ ] it was scary
thank you we're on Holograms yeah we
both we we both
um we took seven or eight grams on this
one because we were dumb but we're like
yo what's eight grams like but that's
the first time ever we ever did in the
dark with no music
so whatever you're thinking it just kind
of like shoots out of your head and
you're seeing it yeah yeah yeah like you
know what I mean like how do you see
stuff without being able to see because
it's pitch black it was a very weird
experience but yeah I was talking about
other world like you're saying like yeah
yeah like a movie like you're turning
Pages like oh I'm here now now I'm here
yeah bro it's trippy it's weird as [ __ ]
I can't even explain it there's no
human explanation to compare it to
except for it's like a movie because
movies show weird [ __ ] that's the only
way I can describe it [ __ ] yeah I was
in a Super Smash Bros world bro in the
meditation
like the Donkey Kong where the rivers
under it you ever play Super Smash Bros
yeah you know the Donkey Kong world
where the there's a river going and [ __ ]
it was like that material textures and
[ __ ] I was just like the game it was
like I was looking at the [ __ ]
environment of that and it was that
material and stuff epic did you look at
your hands
I couldn't see myself it was like I was
you were a camera yeah that's how I've
already told you my trip I looked down
but my body's not there but I could feel
my body in real life
like I couldn't even look down or up
because like I was with my eyes closed
type [ __ ] you feel me like I was just
looking at this [ __ ] Video Game World
I feel so fun yeah it sounds true
I smoked Salvia before I realized don't
smoke Salvia you ever smoked Salvia
before no that's scary bro it's scary
because I feel like it's the worst
feeling it's like having a mushroom trip
in a minute and a half hell no don't I
don't advise anyone doing Salvia
it's way more intense than [ __ ]
mushrooms but it's like this
uh when you say Video Game World do you
remember those commercials Travelocity
and it was all cartoon
I went to cartoon world one time in off
of uh
Salvia just like that but I was talking
to some lady it was crazy so when you
said I'm like whoa so when you well you
look around you're like
cartoon yeah that's [ __ ] that's what
you said like oh was it a good feeling
no it was the worst feeling yeah man
that's scary just because it was scared
could it have no as soon as you come off
Salvage it's like uh it's like your
brain's not firing right you're like
what happened what am I doing if like 15
minutes you're kind of just out of it
you're not here on Earth huh no you're
gone I zoomed into my lap I was looking
at my hat on my lap
and I was on my own lab on my hat
looking around like Honey I Shrunk the
Kids with Leo when that guy almost tried
to kill us or look my friends tell the
buff and he freaked out on this album
and was looking at all of us like he was
gonna start beating the [ __ ] of us
and we're like dude we can't he'll kill
all three I've seen those possession
troops on YouTube yeah like people like
possessed like he was looking at us like
he was about to [ __ ] [ __ ] that virus
and Leo just saw a buff and biggest [ __ ]
I'm like oh [ __ ] it's like a lion I hope
this lion doesn't want to [ __ ] eat me
today that's how I felt so no I don't do
salary anymore hell no yeah you could
you have got that [ __ ] that stores back
in the day yeah it's still legal I think
you can go to smoke shops it's the worst
There's No it should not be legal bro it
should not be legal anymore
ain't no way bro that's crazy I
guarantee you it's still legal
that's just gross it's gross we have the
90s no I haven't what is that I don't
know it's like a plant I've never done
it either I've never done it oh hello
people that do it though really yeah
they get the powder from the plant and
then mix it with water and they're like
bro it feels like lean it feels like
pills wait I I don't I mean I know
people we need Goblin to explain the
[ __ ] or something because yeah I don't
feel like he did once
oh you drink it you can't smoke it no
it's it comes in pills or it comes in
like powder or something so you get that
the smoke shot too I'm cool we went to
the convention in Vegas they had hella
crane cranum booths crates yeah whatever
it is crazy I love them like bro ew I
don't know I don't get a good feeling I
don't get a good feeling from that it
sounds like Plankton from SpongeBob
don't want that chocolate my friend that
[ __ ] sounds scary than a home right it
sounds disgusting actually and scary and
good Read's enough I'm [ __ ] yeah I'll
smoke some [ __ ] I ain't gonna take
powders oh yeah the [ __ ] to me if I want
to ramp it up I'll get a [ __ ] some
dabs
um
real quick question sure
we do something
well we do something we just started
something Marty had an idea we use
segments on the show Okay so this
segment's called where you at and Marty
made this up so where you at is
basically we're going to give you two
things you go where you at with this
and that's it okay so like oh where you
at with [ __ ]
fighting getting jumped like you know
what I mean like what's the question we
need to find a better description
because that was
because I can't say horrible things yeah
yeah because because these are very
normal domestic things that it's like
domestic violence or not like see I
can't say those things like I just said
because it'd be funny to me but you know
we're in trouble that [ __ ] would be
funny see thank you appreciate it so
where you at Marty go for it [ __ ] I'm in
the dope as usual podcast
I'm rolling sorry go ahead John do me
the biggest favor ever I got some weed
could you roll ah we got a legend in the
building by the way two more joints
dang it's DJ Khaled everybody
thank you gaddington City shall we do it
do it
go go ahead
yeah yeah it's a donut yeah
there's some more depths
yeah thank you
oh yeah let's go they have that yeah oh
[ __ ] oh God
roll uh one donut one regular
okay thank you sir
um
yeah which ones you give them Gary
Payton or is it pink Peyton what is it
for sure
thank you guys I appreciate it no
problem
sorry where you at
so where are you guys he's gonna ask you
and that's it you just tell us where you
have I'm ready these are basically all
germaphobe related to start off
where are you at with the five second
rule Things fall on the ground are you
I'm gonna be straight up honest with you
family I'm not eating that [ __ ] thank
you as soon as it hits it's over it's oh
yeah trashington
trashington City at the end of the day
is that how you feel too usually yeah
Barty had the 15 second rule on here and
then I was like wait 15.
if I'm at my house then I'll eat it
depends on where you're at in yourself
and in public oh public anything like on
some Seinfeld [ __ ] well uh this shoelace
touched him before the men's bathroom
and it's gone
yeah that's belt dinged against the
urinal oh bro you know how many times
I've done some share of my all right my
right knee touch the [ __ ] inside of a
urinal [ __ ] let's go get some watch
let's watch this [ __ ] all I just think
of like the dirtiest person on Earth
situations how about in Bill's stadiums
they got you pissing in a trough I don't
know that's [ __ ] disgusting I've done
I've seen that I think it was the A's
Studio you know from the bay it's the
A's what happened the uh
where they have the trough and they
don't even have urinals it's just one
big I'm gonna be real too bro I've never
been to an A's game only I've known
Giants games oh okay okay never mind is
it the Giants game do they have urinals
I don't remember
I can't remember guys I was one of the
[ __ ] teams maybe it was a Raiders
stadium I was a kid and there was a
trough and there was ice and I was like
it's prehistorical goddamn trough
they do have that pretty sure okay so I
did see that all right it might have
been yeah I'm not tripping I'm not sure
been a minute since I've been doing
Giants game though bro I'm not gonna be
like hey what's up bro
don't touch my wrist also there's piss
splashing and you're just splashing get
away from me why was there what why was
there icing there always is I've never
seen ice in that I've seen ice somebody
leave it in the comments people that go
to games a lot somebody's you ever seen
ice in the trough and everybody pisses
in it it's one long mortifier
I guarantee you were in the comments
like yeah Oakland A's stadium
I guarantee you guys I've seen it I was
a kid
[ __ ] just disgusting all right five
second rule you're done
well I think I know where you're gonna
be out with this one where are you at
Raw Dog and door handles
public are you always covering yeah same
same like let's say it's 7-Eleven yeah
definitely yeah super nice restaurant
maybe I'll catch you with the elbow
but I'm never going like this nice
restaurants I I do like the finger the
finger the fingers fingers are not too
bad the one finger I do a lot when I got
[ __ ] in my hands I'll do the one finger
and go like that and kiss man Santa it's
just for peace of mind
it's not clean I just this is for peace
of mind bro this is a good segment right
yeah exactly no because yeah I think
about this [ __ ] all the time is this the
first time you guys done this second
okay what was it Goblin first yeah yeah
Goblin last week all right Goblin's
funny as [ __ ] nah bro he is
the first time I met that [ __ ]
person I could not believe that I was a
real [ __ ] character like the way you
haven't subscribed to him for so long
that's that's him that's literally the
same [ __ ] guy you see any it's the
same dude yeah that's what makes me
happy yeah yeah I see him like oh on and
off camera that fool was tight that's
what makes me stoked yeah he's got um
good energy
yes
here
thank you I got those [ __ ] shirts
right over here the Suge Knight oh the
cigar okay you ready
go
up next where you're at with knocking on
wood being superstitious about [ __ ] OCD
style number things in your head
I do knock on wood I do knock on wood
I knock on wood for show but he does all
the time you can't say some [ __ ] without
it yeah I'm not sure why I'm not I don't
even know why I do this I started
Michael John and put this [ __ ] in my
head oh no and the numbers thing he did
it to me he's like you know what TV
would blow up like TV will blow up on an
odd number on the TV what's a numbers
thing odd numbers okay odd numbers of
people that count OCD [ __ ] that [ __ ]
sucks like I would have never thought
Goblin said he only goes up volume on
the TV oh increments of ten he's like
only 10 only 20. so some OCD [ __ ] like
people have little weird things I have
the same [ __ ] like honestly
even amount of cash only I'd never heard
of that before that's gobbling he's like
I only can carry even amounts of dollars
like wow
I've never thought like yeah me neither
you know all right so this is knock on
wood that's that's the um furthest you
go with that yeah I do that she'll be
hey don't say that about it
so I don't do anything like that but
I also don't speak about things that I
don't want to happen so I feel like
that's so much manifesting yeah true
yeah that's our words are powerful bro
yeah our thoughts are powerful too yeah
three months ago I know this I'm gonna
quit I know what I'm gonna do and here
it is yeah that's that's manifestation
right there yeah it's crazy bro good on
that it's crazy
um all right up next John's John's roll
a joint anybody want to smoke this right
now or you want to take a dab what's
going on
all right now if you had to choose one
deepsea K diving cave diving or jumping
out of a plane
where you at jumping out of a plane
I'm not going deep CK diving don't you
feel me you know what
cave diving looks fun like going in the
actual caves and [ __ ]
crawling in type tight spaces
yeah I would do like easy ones not like
[ __ ] professionals you see those
those YouTubers that are like closed
through a [ __ ] Circle oh that's just
crazy I would do like an easy one but
I'm not claustrophobic I'm not so I'm
good I'm good with that like I can be in
the smallest I can sleep better I think
if I'm like in a small ass space
especially as a kid you sleep on your
side no I can't do it no more [ __ ]
it's not good for your back so I just
stress I'm trying to do things to not
[ __ ] up my because I hurt my background
as a kid so it's always been [ __ ] up
from Sports uh so I used that and I used
to do weight lifting I used to do my
whole family does moving companies so I
was still moving in my whole life wow so
I [ __ ] my back picking up heavy ass
[ __ ] yeah thinking I'm cool picking up
[ __ ] by myself look [ __ ] you my cousin's
worked with me but it was cool it was
dope as [ __ ] like Littlefield a Hercules
like don't worry in five years your
back's done and then that's what
happened so yeah all the above
all right uh yeah I don't think I could
see going putting the caves underwater
is a whole nother thing if you want to
watch a crazy ass video watch uh cowboy
Cerrone on Rogan's podcast he went uh he
was like somebody that would like
strategically map out caves underwater
you go in there with like you know it's
like you did like volunteers for that
[ __ ] but he went in with somebody and
like he went in and they went off course
or some [ __ ] and then they all you got
to do is kick up some soap you kick up
the bottom a little bit now you can't
see anything you can't see the person
you're with you drift apart and it's
[ __ ] over
and he are you serious yeah it was
horrifying listening to him talk
describe he's a professional athlete and
he was trapped in these caves describing
I think I've heard it I've heard that
one was horrified that's cool that
sounds so [ __ ] scary do you guys like
swimming I like swimming in you do pools
really I don't [ __ ] with that [ __ ] in
pools
do you know how to swim yeah I mean I
can I can swim is it a germ thing is it
a public pool thing you're getting at I
just man I just don't find it Fun
swimming yeah I don't find it funny you
go underwater yeah going underwater and
laying on your back in the bottom of the
pool is the most fun I've ever had in my
whole life to this day it's the best
thing ever but you'll die under this you
have to come back up and I can't [ __ ]
sink I can only flow because I'm [ __ ]
buoyant
no we're about to get a pool and I'm
gonna become a [ __ ] fish I haven't
been swimming I can't get fast like I
was thinking chlorine's got the best
branding of anything of all time why
because people are like but there's
chlorine in the water there could be a
[ __ ] dead body in the water people
are like it's chlorine in the water it's
fine oh yeah you're right you're worried
you're [ __ ] it it's chlorine it's
clean yeah I don't I don't like chlorine
yeah it hurts your eyes when you're in
the bottom of the pool trying to look up
chemical right I don't want that [ __ ]
all over here to begin with yeah you're
not wrong it's a camera you're not wrong
a chemical so it's like people are all
four that's what I'm saying it's got the
best like press of all time people are
going any public pool that anybody's
ever been in because of chlorine also
there's no sharks in the sky or giant
squids yeah I'm [ __ ] skydiving
exactly that's one variable but it's a
professional too
that would be scary as hell though I
wouldn't I don't know I don't know what
amount of money
it would take for me to jump out of a
plane but it's got to be astronomical
it's just covering my funeral costs not
even that I'm thinking like so if I die
I could have made no help
you should go I think you should do it
you could take a trip to dabbington City
you can do that I'm done with that on
the way back to Davidson City then jump
out of the monkey
that's not gonna help it I don't think
bro all right that that leads into our
next where yet actually
because you're you're in these places
using all different kinds of devices
right you're not limited to the pen yeah
you got blunts you got papers you got
bonds you got your dabs you got your
pens you're all over the place with the
shed yeah if you had to pick only one
for the rest of your life where are you
at which one are you picking joints
joints really yeah that's the best way
to smoke that's the best way to smoke
I'm in a backward phase right now I
smoke a lot of backwards but I always
end up going back to the joints going
back to the joints do you spot yourself
smoking backwards because you like the
tobacco 100 yeah it's like the little
fun spice kick it's fun yeah yeah that's
what I hear from all of my homies like I
said cakey I like it that's fine but
it's tobacco
yeah it is it is
but I don't want to do your own thing
everybody does their own [ __ ] bongs I
think was my favorite until recently
because I oh people always ask me like
bombs are always going to win but you
can't just walk around like this with a
bomb and I think that's why being able
to I'm not saying I'm driving
but being able to be in a car and listen
to music and doing [ __ ] and smoking a
joint is the best it's the it's the most
fun thing in the world not driving yeah
not driving
that's right parked out front of the
cribbington yep completely parked not
even keys and bumping music on my phone
back in the back [ __ ] Maybach coming
soon yes yeah yes yeah that's right yes
do you have cool glass though are you
into that [ __ ] like I don't I have a 60
like China uh bong yeah all right I feel
we're gonna have to hook them up yeah
for sure
I just bought that piece as the first
cool piece I've ever had in my life
because I feel you like oh I just use a
peek just I don't really care that much
yeah they break too man I've had a nice
I've had like 200 dab rig before in it
breaks your heart yeah
and it's not like the money is more of
like
how it's gone yeah
exactly yeah especially it's emotional
yeah it's emotional it's like that's my
[ __ ]
thank God but I've only I've only broken
one piece
and yeah it was like [ __ ] 20
something give a [ __ ] but still that's
why I didn't give a [ __ ] you haven't
broken a piece since then
nice not me yeah I mean hey I've had
friends
exactly
all right what's up last one
if you had to pick either one music
person or one YouTube channel for life
you could only you have one subscription
for life it's got to be a music person
or a YouTuber
who is it gonna be wow Marty
the hardest question I've ever seen
okay music I'm saying Michael Jackson
bro good [ __ ] that's my favorite artist
oh my God we're okay here we go Michael
Jackson's your favorite artist do you
like baby Michael Jackson like or like
20 year old Michael Jackson [ __ ] I like
all the phases I like all the phases man
me too he's so sick interesting
musically cool answer I like that answer
when I was [ __ ] five years old bro my
dad would just play the videos of
Michael Jackson performing his shows and
I'll just watch that [ __ ] on repeat and
dance to him
and try to copy his [ __ ] dance moves
and [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] Michael Jackson heavy he's
my favorite artist Bro [ __ ] yeah cause
usually we have Michael Jordan Michael
Jackson
that's usually one of the questions
oh [ __ ] all right so what's your time
hold on what's your top three favorite
artists
oh [ __ ] that's hard bro that's way too
in in
genres you can do it pop music Michael
Jackson is a pop artist game of Pop
oh [ __ ] ticker yeah [ __ ] young leans
up there for sure young lean
[ __ ] lately I've been listening to a
Lot Like Larry June and baby smooth
music Legend's awesome yeah I [ __ ] with
Larry yeah Legends though
I like motivational music nowadays like
who like what like Mary Joan baby some
of us you know what you're right Larry
June is very motivational actually you
got to get him on here Jim's dope yeah
homie that would be [ __ ] dope
oh all right you listen to a lot of
Larry baby smooth why do I feel like
I've not heard this he's from Detroit I
don't know if I've heard of him yeah yes
I don't know if I've heard before
all right Michael Jackson what else you
listen to
um rock music like what like [ __ ] emo
[ __ ] I like like what American football
that's a band yeah I like this one small
band I'm gonna put y'all [ __ ]
on Daphne loves Derby look this [ __ ] up
the song Hammers and hearts that [ __ ]
slaps you for me it's like new Emo music
nah they're from the early 2000s it's
like oh yeah Korean Korean singer guy
but the band slaps no [ __ ] they're not
even together anymore I think Daphne
loves Derby is fire [ __ ]
foreign
yeah I listen to weird-ass music the
first concert I ever went to was AFI and
Green Day oh [ __ ] yeah AFI is badass
that's one of my favorite bands too bro
I really love AFL oh so you like you
like Emo music like I do too I think we
all have that nuts I was just bumping My
Chemical Romance out of nowhere the
other day I was like you know what yeah
takes me back that's what my sister
likes takes me back Marty's like I don't
know
Marty's from New York yeah Marty's from
New York and only listen to hip-hop so
we had to put him on a little bit
it's very uh educational push my hair
down this way I was just in New York for
the first time man I saw that it was
beautiful New York City yeah it was
crazy I loved it it's so much different
from California I still don't know that
you're you're from here we went to New
York for the first time this year blew
my mind it blew my mind Frisco had been
a Frisco many times what the [ __ ] the
vibe was great yeah it was great
positive nobody was being a [ __ ]
yeah I seen some mouses on the street
though yeah I only saw one you did yeah
I was expecting like a splinter and [ __ ]
[ __ ] Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles I
was expecting monsters I saw we saw one
but that [ __ ] was a cat he was
huge he was a huge ass [ __ ] it was a
crap
it was at least like the size of a
Subway sandwich [ __ ] but that's the only
one we watched the only one we saw I was
expecting mountains yeah every time I've
been there it's [ __ ] hasn't been like
that but they're there
I didn't see Hector I was over
exaggerating I definitely saw multiple
um
I never really saw too many rats and
[ __ ] in SF hello I haven't made them hit
it though maybe I'm tripping I've been
there a long time tripping right now I
don't know because there is human feces
and [ __ ] for damn sure SF is pretty San
Francisco is is bad yeah yeah it's so
bad now it's [ __ ] bad my sister went
and her Windows got busted and she
didn't live there she was there for like
minutes and I know a lot of fools that I
know live there leave their windows down
like yo just there's nothing please
don't bust the windows because those are
just breaking Windows everywhere man
that's smart leave your window down yeah
it's actually smart all right so I
should just got busted I need to get it
tinted I need to get it tinted
not even an SF goddamn [ __ ] like
25 miles east of SF
I got bit damn it yeah we at a
restaurant yes yep that's where it's all
and there was [ __ ] like
thousands of dollars worth of camera
equipment in the car there was hella
weed in the car but they didn't take
anything
this [ __ ] broke my window and he
bled on the car like there was blood on
the car door and like my weed was up
[ __ ] yeah there was weed in the front
there was hella camera equipment in the
back he didn't touch [ __ ]
it's weird it was so weird definitely
cut his wrist open and bounce bro you
died oh [ __ ] died Marty yeah that'd be
crazy
his hands just in your window with like
[ __ ] glass all 360 around the arms he
was unprofessional bippered ain't there
no professional bipper who's actually
like taking [ __ ] from Cars
a little the little busted that what is
it they have a tools it's crazy cracks
the window so fast it's [ __ ] up I've
seen fools
uh full-on cars just get taken bust the
window they put it I don't know how
they're doing it but they're putting
these cars in neutral or pushing them
and then they turn them on because
they're loud as [ __ ] what the hell kind
of cars like I won't say what kind of
cars like yours if you came in yeah
those cars yeah I've seen them getting
damn but it's on like the Midwest I've
been seeing these videos but girl these
guys are good as [ __ ] with some of these
cars that's 30 seconds gone damn dude
that's crazy bro thanks Kevin Insurance
who cares take my car bro thanks I got
paid up um
you think if my car got stolen I could
get another one yes I can if it was
legitimately stolen yeah yeah
I'm trying to put things in here do you
have insurance and that's what it's for
oh [ __ ]
is that you thinking yeah I was just
thinking real quick all right about some
some bad Queens
but yo do you have a grinder yeah can we
get that back yeah
don't throw it
kidding oh you're done
hey thank you my friends
thank you Sarah which one's a donut
donut oh my God
let's do this
I'm Gonna Roll Up the crystal do it I'm
about to smoke some Crystal family oh my
God
literally I'm not even lying for
everyone that's not watching and they're
just listening in the car that's what
the brand of weeds go please don't think
that today's uh gas fulcrum over here no
I'm just smoking crystal at the end of
the day
foreign
at the end of the day it's fire too it's
absolutely fire
let's go hey
thanks man appreciate it those are nice
all right this one's the donut
Dash it's [ __ ] fat
so what'd you do while you're in New
York
so one of my homies that I've been
producing music for since 2018 he threw
a concert
uh yeah and he's been he's toured around
the states and she he makes Firehouse
music
um yeah he's my homie that's awesome and
he performed I just went out there to go
to the concert I was in Las Vegas right
before that too and I just
I wanted to spend November traveling and
going to new places I went to Vegas I
went to L.A New York we went to [ __ ]
Vegas November and New York in November
wow damn we're on the same [ __ ] man
together actually we're on the same [ __ ]
I feel like I've seen you live in New
York this year bro what do you mean like
that's great I've seen you on the live
stream yeah yeah
we were we were in New York uh
end of November right
midnight beginning of November yeah what
are you doing out there we're doing a
pop-up for the double shot oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah we're doing a pop-up yeah can you
do that in any state like a pop-up yeah
I mean it's all legal are HAC is legal
everywhere you do it in Indiana you can
do it anywhere yeah we did one in
Indiana it was crazy that is crazy yeah
that [ __ ] was sick do we know when
Houston is Houston is January 22nd yep
January 22nd yes people are [ __ ]
waiting on that yeah we're gonna start
we gotta start promoting that [ __ ] right
after Christmas 22nd damn
yeah Houston
um we don't have the location yet but we
do
your smile tells me not
oh you don't remember okay okay but yeah
we got the location uh we're gonna
announce that [ __ ] soon what
BC Smoke Shop so that's the last one was
we we did what Huntington Beach Merced
right that was that was just for my for
me oh yeah no that wasn't an awesome
yeah
um we did Huntington Beach Indiana New
York Miami Miami we just did and then
we're gonna finish off in Texas finally
done do you like flying are you do you
[ __ ] with that or no uh I don't mind it
you don't mind it okay no sometimes it's
annoying you feel me I like the um the
jsx that's nice the jet Suite oh you
like that [ __ ] okay that's where he
flies I don't like flying it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah there's turbulence
on that [ __ ] bro I'm so happy I didn't
fly back with him last time he told me
it was awful well [ __ ] just like the
regular
um airplane especially if it's like a
[ __ ] like six hour five hour plus
flight Bro [ __ ] it's like you're sitting
in in between people I don't [ __ ] with
that [ __ ] yeah no it's the worst I just
I I just can't I hate flying so much
dude just because them in the sky and
it's scary as [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I always
just had a had a bad experience at LAX
bro
experience God damn it
um I got caught taking dabs in the
bathroom
how long ago uh this was a
I need to hear this this was a couple
weeks ago oh [ __ ] am I allowed to talk
about this can you tell me I mean did
you talk to your lawyer I'm not in
trouble you're not you're not in trouble
no like the cops came and they said we
don't even give a [ __ ] bro but they let
you down and this is over in the and the
whole thing's done so basically um
before you start saying it like you're
not in trouble they make a call a lawyer
you didn't go to jail you get arrested
they let you leave or get on your flight
and go yeah yeah yeah so basically this
is what happened I got caught I got
caught in the bathroom
taking trips to dabbington city and then
the security guard saw me and then he
called the cops he was in there nah he
walked in on me when I was taking a trip
to babington city were you in the stall
no I don't know what I was thinking bro
I was up for hella long I was like
tripping I was tripping bro I don't know
what the [ __ ] I was thinking bro I don't
know what I was thinking so he walked in
you're taking a dab off what off my
proxy you know you're smoking a pipe
that's glowing and he walks in yeah and
then he's like hey bro so basically
um I'm gonna call the cops on you you
can try to run or you could just try to
talk to them honestly if you run it's
gonna be bad
you feel me and so the cops come and
then they told me
uh what were you doing in there I was
like I was just um vaping sir because at
the end of the day it is Big yeah I was
vaping he was like bro honestly we don't
care we don't care this is kind of like
a waste of our time bro of course it is
um they don't want you to fly anymore
Delta Air they don't want you to fly
anymore and then I told him I was like
look officer I don't know what I was
thinking I'm sorry I just need to get
back home he's like you seem like a good
kid I'm gonna talk to them and tell him
like
um
it was a mistake and like you're not a
bad kid type [ __ ] you feel me like real
[ __ ] real [ __ ] and then he talks to them
for a couple minutes he comes back to me
he's like so they're gonna let you fly
but you have to go through TSA again and
honestly he said you're gonna be you'll
you'll be valid um we're just looking
for like if you have pounds of flour and
[ __ ] I don't have any flour I didn't
have any flour on me I was like okay
I'll go to TSA again I went to TSA
I put my Yeezys in the goddamn thing it
comes out the other side and then my
shoes are missing bro these
[ __ ] snatch my shoes bro
yeah
I was valid though I flew home did you
say anything yeah I was like yo um my
shoes didn't come out
um they're like with the shoes you were
wearing yeah they were they just ignored
me bro they were just ignoring me
they're just acting like I wasn't there
and I got pissed I was like [ __ ] you
guys
and then um yeah basically yeah you walk
the airport with no shoes yeah
what the [ __ ] I posted on my Snapchat
too I was like yeah they just kept them
yeah they kept your shoes you were
wearing yeah
bro what the [ __ ] I'm so sorry for your
experience
I mean like I guess I was in the wrong I
was smoking in there bro I should don't
smoke in the airports bro that was a
lesson I had to learn bro go steal your
[ __ ] those steal your Jesus that was
a lesson I had I'm shocked that is the
CR they said what are you gonna do about
it basically basically they didn't even
respond to me
you look down and go I don't have shoes
to wear yeah I was like [ __ ] this I'll
just fly home with no shoes and then I
didn't um put shoes on until I got to
Oakland and I got in the Uber
and I opened up my suitcase
damn they [ __ ] robbed you they
literally even try to hide it yeah she
was whack but the thing is how did they
take them out of the machine before they
got through
I'm not sure bro that [ __ ] is so crazy
right that [ __ ] is so crazy bro
I mean it's not like you were like
[ __ ] up and forgot shoes do you think
they did it as Revenge yes to like
because I was smoking in the back I had
to have been and they let you still
through yes had to have been because
you got your shoes stolen yeah
they're just the Yeezy slides but still
you're you're walking with nothing on
your feet yeah I was kind of sad I'm
gonna be realized defeated I was like I
just want to go home I got no shoes [ __ ]
I sent you a message loud and clear yeah
bro but it is what it is bro I learned
my lesson I shouldn't have been smoking
in the airport I'm a jackass I'm a
jackass bro shouldn't have been but also
it isn't given grounds to take your
stuff I'm a [ __ ] jackass
damn the fact that they let you go is so
amazing this isn't it in New York this
was in LAX oh that's right you said LAX
that's right and you oh you were flying
California to California yeah but
basically I just it was from New York to
California but I had hella layovers for
some reason I had to go to LAX to
Oakland
I went from New York to Minneapolis to
goddamn LAX to Oakland bro I don't know
why I signed up for that flight bro I
was tripping I didn't look at it bro I'm
like oh a cheap flight got it oh bro
I've done [ __ ] like that so many times I
actually signed up for the wrong English
class in college and I stayed in it and
it was it was class for English Second
Language why'd you stay in it because
there was no other classes and there was
a credit and I had to get my credits
over a certain amount for them to pay
for my classes that's tough
it was real it was remedial English now
you had to run in with a Taco Bell
employee also oh I saw some of this what
happened what happened
[ __ ] bro
um I learned a lesson this day too at
the end of the day necessarily
uh [ __ ] basically one day I was
filming a video at Taco Bell I was
smoking no wood in the Taco Bell
bathroom oh [ __ ] I haven't done this
since then I haven't done this since the
Backwoods this is not nerve-wracking for
you sitting there just boxing out a
[ __ ] bathroom no one's somebody's
gonna come uh not really because in
Antioch it's different it's different in
Antioch but basically
the Taco Bell employee I went inside the
goddamn Taco Bell after our hot box in
the bathroom and I was like my bed I was
so it took so long in the bathroom I
sharted my pants do you guys have some
napkins and then he leans in um he's
like what did you say he said what'd you
say I was like yeah I started my pants
and then he grabs my GoPro and like he
forcefully took it from me type [ __ ]
like violently like he violently took it
from me and then [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ]
yeah basically he's like I'm gonna call
the cops I'll give it back to you when
the cops get here type [ __ ]
and then I just dipped I did
but then basically I came back like an
hour I came back maybe like 30 minutes
later to I was like bro I'm not taking
the L on this [ __ ] I'm getting my GoPro
back yeah I went back an hour later
the cop was there I was like oh [ __ ] and
I [ __ ] talked to the cop and the cop
was like yeah I've seen your videos bro
I was like he's like you're funny he's
like you got to keep going he's like you
just
hold on you got away and went back saw
that there was a cop there and still
went in there you try to get your [ __ ]
back yeah bro cause there's no running
for me bro like yeah there's no running
from it bro and you want your [ __ ] back
too yeah [ __ ] that I wanted my [ __ ] back
but the cop was cool I guess you know so
he said I've seen your videos he's like
yeah he's like you're gonna hit a
million subscribers bro oh [ __ ] the cop
yeah bro I swear I swear this is awesome
but honestly I've talked to people
before the only way I could really get
in trouble is If I Stay in a location
after they tell me to leave
um
but he's stole your stuff too yeah and
he took the SD card and damaged it so
that video of him didn't get out how do
we probably soaked in the water some
[ __ ] he scratched it and [ __ ] it up
heavy bro what an [ __ ] and so
basically yeah
[Music]
he he gave me my um he gave me my camera
back I go back home and I realize the SD
card's missing
so then I was like what the [ __ ] bro and
then yeah I'm live streaming and [ __ ]
I'm telling my my people's yo my SD
cards my SD card is missing from my
camera and so I didn't tell him what
Taco Bell it was but these people are
smart as [ __ ] they knew what Taco Bell
it was they were calling up the Taco
Bell they're like you still you still
[ __ ] says
and they were like spamming the address
of the [ __ ]
location I did not I did not he didn't
ask for that yeah you didn't ask that or
tell them which one it was and then
basically
um yeah the Yodi family donated to me in
their life don't hit this donut try it
hell yeah
swag thank you family they were like um
uh fulcrum we've been calling goddamn
Taco Bell they say you're at they have
your SD card and you can come and get it
back
because at first I called them like a
few hours before I was like you guys
have my SD card they're like nah but he
was just trying to figure out how to
delete the videos of him off the SD card
I gang you already gang was calling up
the goddamn Taco Bell they're like
where's fulcrum's SD card and then
they're like yeah eventually they're
like yeah we have his SD card he can
come back and get it and he [ __ ]
scratched the [ __ ] out before he got
there yeah he was he was trying to
figure out how to delete the video so
what a [ __ ] dick I feel do you have
the SD card still no I threw it away ah
you should have kept it for some
recovery data [ __ ] I could have
recovered it I think maybe possible I
think someone out there liked your
videos enough to put the dedication in
they're like yeah I know how to do that
that video would have been crazy bro
do [ __ ] that's [ __ ] ah I live
streamed before I went back there I live
streamed on Instagram the same guy yeah
and I confronted him to get my SD card
back because he was because the old
family were they were like yo you can go
back and get your SD card and that was
while I was live streaming on my
computer I was like you already found me
I wouldn't be back from the live stream
in 15 minutes I'm gonna hop on live
stream on Instagram like confronting
this guy and getting my SD card back and
this dude was playing bro he was just
being a [ __ ] bro he's just being a
[ __ ] and I got it all on the live
stream
that's a telephony it's on YouTube
it's on YouTube
well ah damn I really wanted to see if
you got that video back damn you come in
there you box his bathroom you ask him
about sharting your pants and you get
him on his heels after he calls
you talking about starting your pants
that's pretty much exactly what happened
okay so you're not gonna get the video
back the card's gone but yeah it's a
good story
it's a good story also I think if
anybody's taking something from you
you're allowed to take back
uh what do you mean like he was taking a
[ __ ] like I think you could I think
legally anybody out there I don't think
they can take your [ __ ] yeah yeah I know
you're not trying to like I'm not gonna
fight somebody over a [ __ ] GoPro no
for sure I can't I understand what
you're saying but I would say for
everyone out there like that's illegal
can they stop you out like if they see
you stealing something can an employee
oh my God can we stop you out I thought
that's what you said I think so dude is
that what you said yeah like stop you
out if they see you stealing and you
fight back and they end up just stomping
you out or like I don't think they can I
don't think yeah I don't think they can
like like the KFC thing that guy
throwing yeah I don't think you can do
anything no my manager told me to go to
the back go yeah oh um because you you
have to um represent the company
[ __ ] that yeah I've worked that I've
worked at Starbucks for two years too I
was like because of all different
devices customers always right at
Starbucks
that's gotta be nerd you can't be hard
you have to do it customer connections
too what does that mean it's you're
encouraged to do customer connections
you have to um start conversation with
everyone oh God all the customers and
see
what's the interview like at Starbucks
I don't know it's pretty easy I kind of
I've always finessed my [ __ ] bro I knew
how to [ __ ] finesse that [ __ ] hi yeah
turn on your customer service voice and
smile yeah yeah it gets you a long way
it really will like that cop you see my
nice guy yeah you know what I mean like
yeah sir I'm sorry I
apologize I've been up for a long time
my dad taught me that yeah I've seen my
dad get pulled over and just like smile
his way out
shout out to your dad for teaching you
that [ __ ] because I feel like a smile
and being nice goes so [ __ ] far my
dad taught me as a young child too like
you gotta move through life with
conviction and [ __ ]
with conviction
that was the biggest lesson my dad
taught me for so what does that mean to
him
like um
you gotta live with conviction bro like
you gotta um
really own this [ __ ] like you can't
half-ass it you can't half-ass this [ __ ]
what did your dad do
um he's a
he's an I.T uh he works oh computers and
[ __ ] yeah yeah nice oh and oh you're in
the bay yeah all right all right makes
[ __ ] sense he's smart he's very smart
and he dance moves me and he's a runner
yeah [ __ ] Ultra Runner so what is that
that's like 100 over like over marathons
and [ __ ] longer than marathons and [ __ ]
no [ __ ] yeah Rosie did the LA Marathon
that was 26 miles that's a lot that's a
lot a lot of training and [ __ ] that's a
lot of training that's crazy
I me and John are going to do our first
5k soon let's go how that's three miles
three miles that's pretty good yeah it's
just a start we're gonna get high as
hell right before I would have to train
for that and then that's hard oh even if
I walk half I'm like yo I'm out here
doing it and at the end I'm gonna slide
up a joint does he let go up in the
mountains and [ __ ] is y'all stream damn
your dad runs over so what's a what is
the over Marathon what the hell is that
I don't even know bro have you ever been
to any of these before with them my dad
went to the Boston Marathon when I was
in sixth grade and I went to Boston with
my family and [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he ran the
Boston Marathon yeah your dad's legit
you have to qualify for that [ __ ] like
fast bass Marathon no [ __ ] so your dad's
up there he's really good yeah did you
do track at school I feel like you did
long time no I played tennis I played oh
you played tennis all right something
where you're long yeah and have to do
something that's how I feel the sport
you played like my little brother you
something gangly like long because like
you're what two inches taller than me
like we're not like when we stood up I'm
like five almost five nine ish you're
like what five eleven almost six foot
I'm like five ten ish maybe yeah I'll
say you're like this much taller than me
when I met because online you look like
you're 6'10 and [ __ ] so when I'm married
oh [ __ ] you're not a [ __ ] gigantic
person all right all right so when I saw
you I'm like oh this fool does some some
athletic what sport does this team play
that's what I was thinking like water
polo maybe waterfall it's like Rocco you
look around the brother I don't know now
now we talk I know that you don't swim
in pools that's wild I don't know get
high and sit in the sauna I mean I like
hot tubs that's true but just sit in the
shallow into the pool
smoke weed maybe on a hot ass day yeah
on a hot ass day
necessarily perhaps that might be a good
idea yeah that'd be dope as hell
actually I did it my mom my mom has a
pool she lives in the country it's the
weirdest thing to be out in the cuts and
like in a pool of water and I know
nothing but Stars bro that's sick though
it's dope but it's like yo what animals
are that sounds woke as hell it's wild
out there because there's no light
pollution you see every [ __ ] star and
you're in a pool of water oh that's a
mushroom chip [ __ ] my mom does mushrooms
every [ __ ] day now she's micro really
everything oh wow she's wild as hell
micro dosing is kind of cool man yeah
she [ __ ] with it does it work if you do
whatever she loves it
she loves it hmm
there [ __ ] yeah I mean it's like a
medicinal drug [ __ ] hell yeah
it's better than Pharmaceuticals yeah I
mean we're not pushing that YouTube
sorry we're just talking about our own
opinions and [ __ ] over here yeah we're
just talking about Minecraft at the end
Minecraft uh yeah the role play server
we were playing on that's a good
disclaimer
so that is a good disclaimer it's all
talking about games my little brother's
heavy into Minecraft my little brother's
been uh told me about you what three
months four months ago really that's
yeah my little brother watches yours he
told me about Goblin too wow bro's on
that [ __ ] dude heavy he smokes no
he doesn't smoke he tried to smoke but
he didn't like it was a demon yeah I'm a
little brother he was on the show he had
him on the show Once too he's a fool
I think I've seen I hopped in that live
for a bit oh yeah yeah because I tap in
it's every Monday huh yeah every Monday
yeah I've been tapped in appreciate you
man even tapped in let's call Adam 22
one was crazy yeah that fool's [ __ ]
fun he's a wild ass dude like in a funny
way like oh this is you that was a real
question she's like you wouldn't have a
sex with a girl with all right I'm not
gonna keep going into it but but what
this is the wildest question I've ever
been asked
it's like well you wouldn't risk it
I mean she's positive like we're just
gonna leave it at that like that's the
craziest question I've ever been asked
in my entire life I don't even know if I
want to restrict his age age drink this
episode by saying it but he's the only
guy that's going to ask you that [ __ ]
yes yes but he was dope he's a funny guy
he's wild as hell
um all right Marty damn you got more nah
that's just that's dude Marty you're
crushing on these notes are you serious
here we go let's do it he's a
professional [ __ ] Marty damn oh you've
ever done
like on the podcast like the first
podcast you've ever worked on oh no oh
for real yeah I worked on a bunch of
them kind of behind the scenes since
like 2013. [ __ ] it's [ __ ] beautiful
man oh look thank you guys for having me
on bro yeah beautiful the setup you guys
have thank you for being here it's great
yeah but this is the first broadcast
party's like on
various different roles behind the
scenes yeah all that and we made this
one we wanted it to be legendary we
wanted this to be a cool place for
everybody to hang out on Mondays and
yeah and if you don't even if you don't
smoke weed yeah it's still [ __ ] fun
to come yeah let's do an episode we've
had sober episodes before like we've
done that many times just I feel like
the show's more
people we
see out there like do what a
conversation that would be you know what
I mean and when we see YouTubers like I
said we don't really watch YouTube that
much it's the fans that ask so much and
then we go oh draws attention like oh
okay cool yeah so this this one is like
I said from the beginning of this
episode this is the one that people been
asked for at the [ __ ] so thank you guys
for the good suggestion yeah thank you
guys this is good good story it's a good
good [ __ ] oh yeah I like it so where do
you see yourself in the next
no you know what before I asked that
before I forget because I earlier I was
gonna ask it Yogi land
like I said before we started I thought
he was talking about OG
for everyone out there meeting were
talking earlier
yodiland that's what OG calls me calls
me yody all the time so I thought
everybody was tagging that in my stream
yodiland Thomas is in yo you're like oh
okay cool you guys well I love OG that's
a great episode
because he called me yody in those
episodes I'm like oh okay okay I get it
what the [ __ ] is this what does this
come from and you've been saying this
for a long ass time so this is your damn
tagline brand what is this what is where
did you get this from so a lot of people
think that it means just like getting
faded but I've always said Yodi land is
like being in the present moment and
going after like your purpose and your
goals like that you don't even have to
smoke and be in Yodi land
but basically I got the word yody from
2019 me and my homie were just hanging
out we were drinking like hell of beers
type [ __ ] we would call the 40s the 40s
yodies
go to the store and get some yodies
types
of the um
and eventually I just Incorporated it on
the YouTube totally understand now where
you get it from what 40s were you
drinking I gotta know
um [ __ ] we'll get the we would get these
ones the 40s yeah these ones we would
get the corona ones too jump out the
Miller highlights yeah yeah is that the
same [ __ ] as this Miller highlight and
Miller High Miller Light Miller Miller
makes Miller High Life okay yeah Miller
highlights 32s they're like a dollar 40
or 1.60 I remember cheapest [ __ ] that
they're the cheapest one those are the
cheapest one but they're they're pretty
good they're for a dollar or something I
remember I mean they're probably more
now
shall we best believe it God damn it
does it go much further than that
fulcrum come in
oh [ __ ] that was the whole thing all
right that's your whole tagline damn you
should put that on the sticker I think
that would be [ __ ] hilarious to see a
sticker
my dad's making some stickers right now
was it that I don't know he's gonna make
the catchphrase
I'm like Dad make some stickers all
right so hold on you're you're all of
these things are just [ __ ] that you've
acquired in your vocabulary over time
yeah all right makes sense to me like
the [ __ ] makes sense you know how I
like I say stupid [ __ ] all the time you
know how like
Paddington goodington like I'll add
Inked into different [ __ ] yeah yeah it's
like it's just [ __ ] that me and my
homies 100 before I even made the skis
my homies skis weed skis drinks Keys
like it was like all right bro anything
gonna get food skis like all right for
the free ski yeah exactly let me get it
for free skis same [ __ ] it's just
[ __ ] you say with your friends
so now you now every now you got the
world saying all the [ __ ] you see
with your homies yeah I love it
mind-blowing now I get it now I get it
because at first time
so my homies would go to work and
they'll be like oh I seen you in one of
folcrum's videos
yup Side characters
to your whole
show that everybody comes to watch yeah
it's like yo who are your George
costanzas to the Jerry Seinfeld they're
all just as important
but they all play a role
I wanna like because I believe in myself
what do they do music too
oh yeah I mean YouTube no [ __ ] what are
they what kind of videos they make
um yeah so my homies on they're starting
to make like Wii tubing [ __ ] it's good
and [ __ ] yeah but some of my homies have
been producing for [ __ ] hella long
and [ __ ] too make beautiful [ __ ]
music like the homies I was just with in
New York they make crazy music
I got some homies that went to high
school if they make crazy music crazy
beats and [ __ ] too
yeah nice man just gonna keep working
with them bro keep working with my
homies and [ __ ]
that's the whole point of it and you I
mean literally just kind of started dude
yeah right and this is the funnel down
so where can everybody find your music
on all streaming platforms at fulcrum
just search up fulcrum all streaming
platforms SoundCloud
you can find more of my discography on
Soundcloud at the end of the day
yeah so SoundCloud for us for the music
okay so social media wise because on
Insta on YouTube it's a whole different
name yeah Damien look 925. are you ever
gonna switch that [ __ ] no no oh [ __ ]
man that's why I was like Marty's like I
couldn't find your Tick Tock [ __ ] Grace
Grace saber yeah great Savory
eventually if you possibly can just from
from up from a fan branding standpoint
it'd be so if you could possibly ever
get it somewhat similar yeah best bro
because I'm almost like oh that was
definitely the underscore
but at the end of the day
I kind of like you how it is yeah if
you're gonna do whatever you're gonna do
yeah for sure
because I eat my [ __ ] on Snapchat used
to be Brian fantana from Anchorman
and I go you know what I should probably
say topaz all alone then it's a huge
Snapchat she probably just use my real
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then I changed it but
everybody started calling me Brian for
forever and that was my [ __ ] name
every name associated with his shirt is
probably long gone at this point oh yeah
everybody's got every version of very
name you can ever think of fans already
snatched most definitely
dude is [ __ ] mind-blowing the growth
is mind it's mind-blowing it's crazy
yeah
my full-time job I'm about to move out
this month bro I don't know about this
month
that's epic right for Christmas and [ __ ]
too hell yeah hopefully hopefully before
Christmas that would be ideal
that would be epic yeah well you're just
getting started man you got and you
understand it's a marathon so you just
keep setting little goals and just keep
trying to hit new levels and keep you
pushing just understand it never stops
yeah life's just not easy that's just
not easy and it takes up more time than
you think especially when you start
making content then you gotta balance it
yeah
for a while there is no balance it's
work and like yeah [ __ ] it it's worth it
it is worth it yeah especially when
you're doing [ __ ] see when you talk we
don't have like we only have a couple
other people that do weed stuff and make
it a like an actual career yeah so being
able to talk to you about it it's more
of
what you gotta oh my only advice since
since like this is like your full thing
do you edit your videos yes I edit my
videos it takes a lot it takes so much
time it does Marty's my editor I used to
I used to do the skeleton and then we
just started passing it off yeah that's
the one thing I would always suggest is
try to delegate that [ __ ] to somebody I
gotta get someone I trust yeah yeah you
have to get someone you trust and you
have to sit with them for the first like
four yeah and it's like this is how I
would like it and sit with them it
didn't take a while but I promise you'll
be able to put out twice as much content
yeah I bet yeah
will you edit it the first one with them
like this is why I cut that out boom see
that nah this is kind of boring just
move the camera cut that [ __ ] out boom
you got to teach him to think like you
think yep yeah and me and Marty that
were the same [ __ ] Marty would do some
[ __ ] like oh I would have thought of
that
I'm gonna give one of my own used to do
it do it and then you can start [ __ ]
paying your homies and then that's how
it stayed but make sure it's not like
your homie that has to learn right now
still does never end up before very
capable and they you know what I mean
like I would have some homies like yo be
my editor but in a year
first yeah I need someone right now
especially you're in the bag I guarantee
you find that [ __ ] yeah people hit me up
all day too there you go especially Tick
Tock edits this and that you know that's
what you need dude tick tock's where
it's at man I have it I don't use it a
lot
but I should
I know I need to it's about to go down
Tick Tock huh
yeah there's a whole page of the dope of
the podcast that's bigger than our Tick
Tock of the podcast yeah that's crazy
it's [ __ ] crazy that's [ __ ] nuts
it's insane dude we're about to get on
that yeah we're we have it just takes a
lot of time like we're gonna have a team
in about a month yeah in about a month
we move to our new spot like we're
saying so we'll have people helping us
do social media cut Clips do they nice
it's just a full-time job we need
somebody there it takes a long time
all right well dude thank you so much
for being here how long have you been
here two times oh damn two hours damn
what the [ __ ]
yeah that flew back no [ __ ] way 210.
I was expecting 47 minutes yep that's
what happens we always say like when
you're having fun in a conversation
it'll fly yeah when you're just chilling
it's gone that's crazy [ __ ] damn that's
crazy good [ __ ] all right bro I
appreciate both of you guys I appreciate
you being here man thank you for coming
out thank you for driving all this
[ __ ] way just to come to the show of
course man for real though thank you
grateful it was a great Vibes talking to
both of you guys likewise dude it's
exact bro I couldn't have wanted it to
be any other way this was great I right
now me too that one got me hold up I'm
gonna take another trip to sippington
city do it
yeah dude I barely drink this water I'm
dying
Marty
got anything else you want I love that
we're pulling from the community here
and you're out there doing your own
thing and that's exactly what's supposed
to happen and really getting after it
but with the message underneath things
of like
you know trying to inspire the people
and uplift people you know like I got
your attention with this but that's just
the sugar of those medicine here like
this underlying message yeah most
definitely bro
appreciate it the positivity man I
[ __ ] love it I love it I appreciate
you man I appreciate you being here like
I said thank you for driving down here
thank you everybody out there go check
it fulcrum gray saber fulcrum Tick Tock
gray saber fulcrum tick tocker I would
be real I'm not a tick tocker at the end
of the day yeah like sometimes I'll post
some random ass clip or be at a
restaurant with a beer in my hand I'll
save my my [ __ ] in the middle of the
restaurant
middle restaurant hella loud yeah
got to so right after you do it and you
turn the camera you go
no all right like this I'll go like this
and stand there
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
is that what you'll do to them yeah
that's incredible and then they don't
bother you
and they're just looking they're just
the [ __ ] is wrong with this guy
restaurants and the people in the
background are like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with this and do you do it just
because it made me laugh yeah I love you
so much right now bro I'll [ __ ]
pretend to spit in my hand all the time
in front of my homies like why why
because it made me [ __ ] laugh inside
you do [ __ ] just to make yourself laugh
that's why I just did that bro thank you
yeah I'm so happy you respect that I do
oh
yo The Stance I like how you just stun
[ __ ] at their job like what
I would laugh myself if I walked and I
saw somebody doing that
instantly like I [ __ ] with you people in
the comments are like all those dudes
are NPCs in the background
fulcrum how do I get how do I not have
social anxiety and then people reply you
gotta think everyone's an NPC bro now we
are in The Matrix but not everyone's an
NPC ever like we all are human beings we
all live like our complex lives bro yeah
and then today you're not gonna go see
that person like oh that person
embarrassed people's from Iowa I'll
never see him again yeah
also who cares yeah it doesn't matter
what they think and it's like do you
really care
you don't really actually care no no no
no so it's like just do whatever you
want to do
even though they're like what the [ __ ]
is wrong with this [ __ ]
kid
peculiar
peculiar well thank you for ending it
off with that I fixed bit my hand off
and just to make myself laugh so thank
you very much I got you too but I'll do
it for real no don't do it
that actually looked fake as [ __ ] no no
this is way more dramatic yeah mine's
disgusting
actually we'll spit yeah no I feel you
so I love the way we ended this concept
conversation I'm tripping I got dope all
over my dope
you know my homie OG
that's what he would say I got dope on
me damn it
I'm [ __ ] up no I appreciate you man
thank you for being here thank you guys
so much for watching also thank you for
spreading the positive message on your
channel man and hopefully you hit that
Mill soon it's coming that'd be the
fastest I think I've seen anybody ever
in a million man I've been saying
January
things are from your projections you hit
in the back oh [ __ ] that shit's in like
three weeks
maybe middle of January I'm gonna keep
pushing good [ __ ] let's go good [ __ ]
dude oh yeah well Marty thank you very
much for being here thank you guys thank
you very much for being here guys this
has been the dope as usual podcast thank
you so much for hanging out with us have
a dope ass day
we still have one
yeah
good [ __ ] dude oh yeah that was chill
thanks man damn over that was 215. you
guys need to do a lot more sure I was
entertaining I like that that was fun
man that [ __ ] was funny as [ __ ] good
[ __ ]
[Music]
perfect